holy [ __ ]
it's only a half an hour late but we're
here man
welcome ladies and gentlemen to fat man
beyond i'm kevin smith
i am mark bernard hey oh
uh welcome kids we're still socially
distanced
uh because california is a coveted
nightmare right now as we speak
um but more on that
in a second because one of us has
news um before we get to that news mark
how are you this weekend
i am doing pretty good my friend it's
been a it's been a busy weekend we
started a little bit late
because i i had to go look at a house
because i'm house hunting
and uh which is like the worst
experience
um you do you live i mean do you live in
a dwelling net you do you own or rent a
house currently uh i rent a house like
we're renting the same house we rented
when we first moved from new jersey out
here
and you know we began thinking like all
right we're doing okay then
i seem to be you know making money and
working regularly let's [ __ ] let's do
the adult thing that you do which is buy
a house
yeah and uh and then we started looking
and oh god
dude what is expensive
i don't know if you know that but real
estate
yeah in my mind i would have thought
like everything else
like you know since the quarantine it's
all gone in the toilet but jordan
jason's wife jordan monsanto she was
like
last week i was having this conversation
about like now would be a good time to
try to find a building and buy it to
open an office and
instead of renting or something and she
was like not at all now is not the right
time it's a complete [ __ ] seller's
market right now and i'm like why
and you read stories constantly about
everyone's leaving [ __ ] california
and going to texas and you assume that
like all right well that means there's a
lot of open houses
but jersey's the same thing jersey real
estate's through the roof now that's
because
a lot of folks moving out of manhattan
are just going to jersey
i don't understand why real estate is
still so high
in california and mind you you know
nobody's tuning in to hear us talk about
real estate but still it is a question
that demands to be asked right about now
why is real estate so high i think some
of it is
that you know when kovit hit there were
people in the process of selling their
houses and they were like
i gotta go i gotta go i gotta go and
those houses sold and then everybody
else stopped scuffling the house because
like i can't find anybody to buy
everybody's lost their job and i can't
even move anywhere because i don't wanna
[ __ ] risk any of that [ __ ] so people
just changed their minds which meant the
supply went
way down and then the houses that were
around and people who still had
money scooped up everything and so now
like almost a year later the market is
such that if you wanted to buy a house
that's worth
let's say 500 000 which sounds insane to
anybody who's not in new york or san
francisco
or or you know la that same house is now
selling for like almost 900 000
which is an insane amount of money for a
house that i would have spent
you know two hundred thousand dollars
for in new jersey yes
if you were in well not new jersey right
now not now
probably five hundred thousand but if
you were like like nevada
you'd spend 200 grand on that house yeah
totally i want three bedrooms two baths
and a garage and that's it and i'm not
asking for the moon
and apparently the moon now costs more
than anything where are you looking los
angeles town
um yeah los angeles county mostly the
valley because i still have kids that
are in school
and you know i i can at the moment work
anywhere
and you know live anywhere but the kids
got to be where the kids got to be so
it's mostly the valley but it's become
this weird demoralizing experience and
then seeing a house in covid like you
have to sign all kinds of safety [ __ ]
you know there's no open houses anymore
right like
you know there's there's you've got a
window you have 15 minutes to go into a
house and then decide if maybe you want
to spend almost a million dollars on a
house that you saw for 10 minutes
and got to walk around in once um and
then there's another family behind you
and then another family behind you and
then like
a dude with just a briefcase of money
who's like i'll buy this house i don't
care
i'll tear it down and build something
else um because those the other people
who are suddenly driving up the market
is
a bunch of speculators and investors who
are like yeah no i got cash
i'll buy your house i'll get there um
i'm paying attention you keep talking i
forgot to put us up on
instagram so keep talking about the
house thing i'm gonna yeah just
mindful you know all of our nerd
clientele
is like ooh tell me more about the real
estate market yeah welcome to batman on
real estate
i'm kevin smith that's mark bernard and
we're getting into the market right now
shares are up um yes but it's way
interesting to me tell them something
more interesting uh that affects
everybody mark
actually went through something this
week that all of us
you know will hopefully go through
one day relatively soon tell them what
you did mark
indeed this week i i got myself
vaccinated
i got myself a coveted shot part one
look at that now mark as you know is in
the group of 65 to 80 year olds so he's
eligible for this knees are in the group
of 65 80 year olds the rest of me is
still a rose of a young man
the big question is how did you get the
shot
well uh here's here's how it happened it
happened that
i have a child who is both special needs
um and she has epilepsy which according
to the county of la
qualifies her caregivers as healthcare
workers
because if one of us or both of us come
down with it then who is going to care
for this child
that makes that absolute sense so so we
were able to
you know it is a technicality i suppose
um but it's also very true and very real
and you know i i've had some people
online
be like that's not cool but whatever my
grandma doesn't have a shot i'm like i
understand completely
i get it 100 here's the thing
i would gladly not have the vaccine if i
didn't have the reason to have the
vaccine
you know like i've had the same thing at
like disney world
when i'd be online and if you have a
child with special needs or a child with
a handicap like there's passes that you
can get that allow you
um an accelerated access to rides and
whatever
primarily because there's a population
of children who literally cannot stand
on those lines that long
and so we've gotten those access and you
know you've got the people who look at
you shitty
when you're walking through the fastpass
entrance and they're like i've been on
this line for dumbo for an hour and a
half why do you get to go in i'm like
you know what
i will happily create autism for waiting
on that line for a while
no and then they shut up really who the
[ __ ] gets like that tight about like oh
my god two people went in front maybe
three
clearly a family clearly like you know a
decision was made like
just chill you're already in a [ __ ]
line and [ __ ] like that
um but yeah so i went on thursday and
got my first dose
of the moderna vaccine i i have to go
back in february for my second dose
um and i had been warned that there
would be
pain um afterwards um not
during because it's just a [ __ ] shot
you know and they make you sit there for
about 15 minutes to make sure that you
have no adverse
reactions to it but i was told like yeah
no your arm's going to hurt i was like
well how much could it possibly hurt
i've been vaccinated before i
believe in science so i've had measles
i've had my mmr
measles mountain rubella shots i've had
pneumonia shots i've had all kinds of
stuff
no no this is gonna hurt and they were
right um
for like two days just my arm was
[ __ ] killing me
you know not not like couldn't lick
things or couldn't move it but just what
way like
where the stab was it was like an
injection site and then all the muscle
like just right around
it was just store like it had like
bruised um it's faded by now two days
out like it's like
okay i got it i remember where the shot
is if you touch it it's a little
sensitive but not
oh don't poke me i can't sleep on this
arm
don't even nudge me stay away yeah
was it that bad for one or two days it
was that bad for for two days
um what is that is that did they tell
you like that just means it's working
because that's the only way that it
would like make sense to me i'm like why
does it have to hurt
your [ __ ] scientists take the ouchie
away no
hurts so good for you um
yeah they they didn't explain it you
know and as i understand it because i
kind of walked in there like john d like
give me my vaccine
run out just stop [ __ ] hugging people
and shaking hands
and going into restaurants and like i'm
just start living my life they're like
yeah no you can't do that
they're like you still need to wear a
mask you're still into social distance
you still need to
you know do all the things that we've
been doing for the last
whatever year almost because
a nobody else has it b you might not be
able to get it but you can
carry it and you can pass it on to other
people you know it'll it'll help protect
you
but it won't protect anybody else at
this point so keep masking
keep social dismissing keep not doing
the things that you like to do
um and then once hopefully we get to a
place in the summer of the fall
then we can all the more of us who get
vaccinated the more of us can start
doing [ __ ] again and then maybe we can
all go see a movie in a movie theater
again
i'm just dying because you know we do
have
like a young component in the audience
and
so far we've covered like the housing
market
and health issues
people like what is this [ __ ] old man
on batman
like what would you guys talk about
something we care about
but this is something i actually
absolutely care about man we're all
eventually gonna have to get vaccinated
so
mark was our little astronaut he [ __ ]
went first that's important [ __ ]
information man
comicbook.com should write an article
about that
you know fat man beyond's mark bernardin
gets the shots
says it hurts
because you know our people are kind of
soft i'm soft the moment you said hurt
i'm sitting there going like
do i really want this i guess i could
just triple mask uh my wife
made me get in touch with my
cardiologist and she was like you've had
a heart attack you may be able to jump
to the head of the line because of your
health condition
and she'd been badgering me about it for
a month so finally i wrote to my doctor
and he was like if you were younger and
had the heart attack
you could jump he's gone but right now
you're in the 50 to 65
group which is 1c we're currently on 1b
which is 65 to 80 year olds he's going
so
they're not going to jump you he goes
just stay stay the [ __ ] side so i was
like well dude
if you're younger or if you were older
you could check the line
that's true sucks being 50. everything
about it
um all right man so uh you know we
we've talked about our personal lives
and [ __ ] like that for me i'm sure i
talked about last week
i finished clerks three i did a second
draft this week which was even
[ __ ] better got some great notes and
i was like ooh you're right and went
back in and
and my second draft has more content and
is one page shorter
that's [ __ ] writing lean hundred
pages i'm very proud of that
um what else happened this week uh we on
janesylembob.com which is our
website where we sell [ __ ] we just
rebranded the website it used to be the
website for just the secret stash
now it's the website for all things jane
bob we moved
the website fulfillment center out here
to los angeles so me and jay can sign
everything and stuff
this week we put up um 2 000
pops signed silent bob and kevin smith
director pops and stuff
and i honestly thought they'd be up
there for a month and [ __ ] put up one
instagram post
gone in eight hours done all sold out
and stuff
so they're we're getting just heads up
this week we're getting the
j-pop um which was even harder to buy
and this is the j from j and zombob
reboot um
the uh this one
that bad boy so we'll be getting this
one and only a thousand of them and
jay will tag him and they'll probably go
[ __ ] fast so check out
janesonbob.com if you want to get a jump
on that or
shop all jane zombop stuff um all right
enough with oh you know what we got to
do before we do anything yeah i was just
doing my own [ __ ] ad for my own [ __ ]
but i'll tell you right now jay and
zombop don't pay me these bills ladies
and gentlemen you know who pays our
bills this week
the the glorious wonderful folks
at keeps the people that are trying to
[ __ ] help you
keep your hair as we sit here and speak
about keeps you go to keeps.com
slash fat man right now so you can read
along as we talk
about this man you're going to receive
your first month of treatment
for free that's keeps.com fat man you'll
look at it right now
as guys folks uh so much of our identity
is wrapped up in our hair uh we know
this um
i started losing my hair at a young age
25 my mom even pointed it out to me
i felt ashamed and stuff had keeps been
around
i'd have a lion's mane of hair today man
i'd have more hair than mark bernard and
[ __ ]
but sadly keeps is only uh part of this
world
not my [ __ ] ancient world not the 90s
and [ __ ]
keeps.com ladies and gentlemen these
folks uh
ship you product you don't have to go to
the doctors no more they do like an
online consultation then they
ship you the product every few weeks man
you don't even leave
your house for heaven's sakes man you
know two out of three guys
will experience some form of male
pattern baldness by the time they're 35
the best way to prevent hair loss is to
do something about it
while you still have hair left may get
treated from home
every three months the medications show
up man so you can say goodbye
to the pharmacy and the checkout lines
and whatnot um
prevention being key keeps treatments
typically take
four to six months to see results so if
you start now
by the time the warm summer months are
are going on
you got your hair man your hair is not
falling out as bad as it was it's
important to act fast the sooner you
start using keeps
the more hair you'll save it's just that
[ __ ] simple man
find out why keeps has more five-star
reviews than any of its competitors
and more than 100 000 men trust keeps
for their hair loss prevention
medication keeps treatment starts at
just
10 bucks a month man plus for a limited
time you can get your first month free
mark here for the hair that's up there
so your scalp don't go bare
i spent the last 10 minutes and get up
some rhyming [ __ ]
and there you go that's a hot 16 right
there my friend
you were spitting fire i should be the
poet laureate
because i could do good keeps [ __ ] ad
copy
there ought to be a picture of you
hanging up at keeps headquarters man
not our right next to our founder that
says our mouthpiece
advertiser of the month me but if you're
ready to take action and prevent hair
loss go to keeps.com
fat man to receive your first month of
treatment for free that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash batman keep your hair
man don't wait don't wait trust us kids
you don't you want to wear a [ __ ]
baseball cap like you're 12 years old
at age 50 no
had i been born in a different faith i
was born catholic had i been born in the
jewish faith
i could be wearing a yamaga that would
solve all my [ __ ] problems
but i didn't have that so instead it's
baseball caps i'm a prisoner
of a backwards baseball cap because i
wear forward
i look stupid look at that look at this
right i've never seen that in my entire
life and i don't know what to do with it
[Laughter]
it looks dumb as [ __ ] man that's why
i've been wearing them backwards my
whole life
people always like what are you just
rebelling against everything i'm like no
i'm trying to make the hat work
and i'll be honest with you when i'm out
in the sun and i wear it like the way i
wear it it's [ __ ] useless
it just makes you sweat and the sweat
pours down your face i wish i could wear
it
bill forward because that's the way
you're supposed to keeps the sun out of
your eyes
but i've noticed man i'm thinking about
i'm 50 [ __ ] years old i've been in
this baseball cap for not the same one
but
in baseball caps since my mid-20s since
my early 20s even
a prisoner don't be that guy keeps.com
you don't want to be [ __ ] kevin smith
i promise you
so go to keeps.com fat man get a month
free
start rubbing that [ __ ] in remember that
[ __ ] remember the
rabbit of seville when bugs bunny was
putting the [ __ ] in
elmer fudd's hair
that's what keeps is going to do for you
ladies and gentlemen give me a head full
of flowers perhaps
um keeps.com is a proud uh sponsor
uh of fat man beyond and we are prouder
than they are of us to have them
sponsoring us thank you keeps.com all
right ladies and gentlemen
after 20 minutes of pre-show it's time
to talk about what we came here to talk
about
yes um one division episode
three debuted uh you know friday morning
i guess it was about midnight or
a little after midnight out here in los
angeles uh i
forgot uh and fell asleep at like nine
o'clock that night
and stuff so when i woke up on friday
morning
you know i was like [ __ ] cruising
reading google news every morning i get
up read all the news and [ __ ] like that
uh and then i was like farting around
and all of a sudden i saw
like something about wanda vision i was
like [ __ ] and i went and watched it
about six
in the morning this was the episode i'll
be honest with you for the first half i
was like i
love the convention of the look at all
these classic sitcoms they're doing
great
looks fantastic they're killing it
visually
what a commitment to a gag but like
midway through the episode i was just
like oh man like they got to get to the
plot
like i get it this is very much like the
brady bunch and stuff and it looks great
and they're
great but everyone's doing great but
it's like i get it i get the clever side
can we
get to the meat and [ __ ] like that so i
wasn't bitching i wasn't like i'm
[ __ ] turning this off but i was just
like all right man i get it the sitcoms
but i want to know the story about the
story
i want to get to the tragedy that's what
i'm here for the meat
and then they [ __ ] served up the big
best slice they possibly could
instantly gave me one of my top 10
favorite moments
in uh marvel studios history if you have
not seen one division
episode three or one two and three kids
plug your ears because we're gonna spoil
the [ __ ] out of it
you've had a few days now so you know
this is on you so if you don't want to
hear about it
go sign off and come back in like 10 20
minutes or so or just mute us and stuff
order your keeps you come back that's
right go cruise the keeps website
keeps.com um the moment
when uh uh um geraldine
who as we know from from reading not
from the show but from reading
the media in advance of the show is
monica rambo
the young girl from captain marvel all
grown up
so uh geraldine is uh visiting with uh
wanda after she's had the twins in a
very sitcoming way
um and they're alone in the house and
vision is walking the doctor out
and so uh you know geraldine goes
like real like somebody i hear somebody
might want to meet
um like in a very sitcoming way
and then elizabeth olson who has been
playing
a wonderful sitcom actress this whole
time
like you know hitting note perfect
but finally gets to like [ __ ] drop
and sh and and show who she really is
and like give a [ __ ] devastating
performance
when she's like i'm i was a twin i had a
brother
jim that what's your favorite chinese
food
who's that what was that
sounds like uh our special guest and his
wife for discussing dinner
he didn't mute and i can't let me see if
i can mute
mute from here a little
bit behind the scenes i know we got a
guest coming up kids and we were just
okay
i got it muted all right um our guests
we were here in a bit of their home life
um
wanda finally acknowledged pietro after
not talking about him since age of
ultron
and it hit a devastating [ __ ] gut
punch
instantly i started welling up man like
lizzie olson [ __ ] sold that moment so
hardcore but then
the actress who plays geraldine slash
monica rambo
whose name i don't know banana paris
wonderful
she crushed her delivery man like the
way you talk to
somebody who has ptsd or somebody who
or a kid who's been through something
horrible or a victim of anything like
where she's very careful
she's like he was killed by ultron
wasn't he like she's trying to like
reach her and in that moment you get the
impression that like
wanda is
they're trying to get wanda the [ __ ] out
like you know they're obviously
she's in there um in a different way
than everyone else in the town
like katherine hans agnes character and
the neighbor and stuff
because they're having a whole scene
outside with vision
where vision's noticing that they're
like having a weird conversation they
ask
like is geraldine in there and she's
like yeah and they start raising
suspicions about her going like
she's new and you know she's not married
doesn't have any kids and vision's like
well that's nothing wrong with that
and katherine han's like and then she
goes no home
like in this real creepy [ __ ] way and
[ __ ] visions like what and they're
building the tension
with this [ __ ] score in the
background man and suddenly you're like
oh [ __ ] the moment it was all happening
man i was like
this is the [ __ ] show i showed up for
man
and so all of a sudden wanda
starts like churning on geraldine and
going like what did you say
what did you say about pietro and she's
geraldine's trying to back up like oh i
didn't say anything and [ __ ]
and she's like do you want me to rock
the baby and like uh you know [ __ ]
wand is like i think you should leave
now like
all cold and [ __ ] and like somebody
popped the bubble for a moment and so
then we saw her get blast out blasted
out of
uh of what is the town called west view
or something like that um and land on
the ground like the shot we saw in the
trailers and then we saw
all of sword show up put a helicopter
light on her and
see the sign and the town is surrounded
by like an electromagnetic
field that looks like tv static and then
they got big lights up to
see it and stuff like that and we
finally get our look
at the story the real story the world
beyond the world we see that they've set
up a perimeter
around the town and stuff like that so i
was [ __ ]
on cloud nine man like i that that
absolutely [ __ ] did it for me that
made
like two and a half episodes of time i
put in when i was like alright it's
clever where are they going
so worth it i rewatched that no [ __ ]
ten times just kept going back to that
moment
where she's like twins and then she's
like i i was a twin
oh my god it's so [ __ ] good and it's
earned because of 10 years of marvel
history
like marvel studios history where you
realize you start to put together like
[ __ ] wanda man you want to talk about
like
somebody suffering from probably from
ptsd
lost her parents lost her [ __ ]
brother lost
vision and [ __ ] how you know god
accidentally got people killed in civil
war
so what a great character to choose
to deep dive with and so much so that
it's going to pay dividends for the rest
of the series
and then into doctor strange and the
multiverse
of madness at this point i'm starting to
think that like
wanda will be the big bad of multiverse
that
it's not you know her and strange having
to work together
but maybe strange has to ultimately take
her out they they're kind of using wanda
now
as their jean grey that's what it feels
like she's kind of building up to a
phoenix
level of power and stuff and you can't
like
bring it all back after that there's
only one place to go so i got
super [ __ ] excited pretended that i
didn't watch it on friday morning and
then watched it again with my
wife on friday night and was like
you know had to react like the whole
thing that i had done by myself this
morning and [ __ ]
and uh she loved it as well again not a
marvel
movie person she's seen a few but i had
to show her
a little bit of age ultron before we
went into this and she was like why and
i was like
it's just kind of crucial like just
there's a piece of wand you need to know
in order to enjoy this episode
and she's like how do you know i was
like i read things online
so i had a blast i thought it was
wonderful
this is the show that i [ __ ] came for
and stuff those moments that they had in
episode one
and episode two like were creepy but
like
you know this this was [ __ ]
a creepy gut punch and then like when
vision comes in he's like wanda where
did
geraldine go and she's like oh she had
to leave honey and they're doing that
score that's like yeah
yeah like those [ __ ] choir kids
voices that's usually like
associated with crazy or satanic people
so right away i was like oh i hope she's
both
um this this is the show i can't say it
enough this is the show that i
was dreaming about and if they continue
on this path which is what it seems like
they're doing
i that's this may be one of the best
marvel studios projects they've ever
produced
mark i'm sure you co-sign and say the
exact same thing
uh yeah
thoughts um
i agree with you that the the
the finally beginning to deliver the
first real
um bit of mystery
data you know because because the
mystery of this show
is really interesting the mystery of
like all right what the [ __ ] is going on
is ultimately the the big mystery um
and beginning to start to tell that
story at the very least beginning to
give us
a little bit of ammunition to try and
put together and try and solve for
ourselves what this mystery is
um and i did i agree that moment is is
fantastic because you know for the first
time one that drops her
weird you know shiny happy american
accent and and the sakovian comes out
you know and and you know geraldine
slash monica is
very tentative almost you know very
starling like
attempt to bridge a gap between somebody
and like very slowly try and like
sideways her into getting the
information she's looking for
all of that stuff is really nice i love
the bit where
you know vision begins to grapple with
the idea that the world isn't the way it
it feels
like haven't you noticed that there's
just like this person's acting weird and
then when that guy was choking at dinner
and then when the guy outside was trying
to saw
the the stone wall and then suddenly it
glitches
and he doesn't have those questions
anymore you know like it's it
totally doesn't call attention to it
it's just and then he's
i muted um it's another moment that
like in episode two when wanda was like
no
and they rewound and kind of went back
but this
was so like glitch cut that i could see
a lot of people out there
having a sopranos moment being like wait
what happened like something happened
digitally
you know but it was the intent and that
was a creepy moment too back to you
um so i'm i'm here for that stuff that
where i'm where i'm still struggling
with the show
is that i don't know
what any of these characters want um
i don't because the show hasn't told me
yet
you know it's it's because it's so much
in this sort of like meta
sitcom daydream believery world you know
i
i do not know week in week out what our
protagonists
are trying to get done what they're
trying to learn what they're trying to
achieve
because the show isn't giving us that so
instead
you know all we have is performance and
the performance
isn't necessarily giving us any
information either
you know like we have theories about
what's happening you and me and the
internet and we are coming to it we're
doing a lot of the work here
we're doing a lot of the work and i'm
fine with like the sort of
conspiratorial viewing like that's what
a mystery show is like who could laura
palmer all right i get it
you know who who killed you know the
pretty young hispanic lady in the
undoing
[ __ ] let's have theories let's let's
play this game
but even while you're doing that stuff
there are characters that you get
to latch onto that you're invested in
that you that you want
to evolve and proceed down this path you
want people to solve the mystery
because you're invested in who these
people are and what they're doing and
like yeah i'm invested in wanda and
vision because i know who they are
but i don't know why they're doing any
of the things they're doing
and the show isn't really telling me and
plot-wise
they're also not trying to achieve
anything you know like
things happen to them we have to do a
magic show i seem to be having a baby we
never had sex but sitcoms
like i i'm wanting more of
them that i'm getting and sure
i have the theory that this is all a big
evasion escape from grief and she's
created this thing or
sword has maybe built this this cocoon
for her because if she experiences this
grief
then she might latch out and destroy the
world so they built a prison
and you know very slowly they're trying
to get information out of her to keep
her from going
nuts which is a wonderfully 1980s marvel
comics view of like
ladies are scary and you know what
happens when they have all of their
powers
we don't know what to do with a fully
activated woman
so we gotta put mental blocks and put
him in jails and all that [ __ ] it's
never that never occurred to me man but
that's very professor x to be like
i've had to [ __ ] with gene's mind to
keep her from becoming
dangerous or something like that so
you're right that could actually
be the case i never thought about that
maybe she's
being maybe she's imprisoned like in my
mind this was all choice
but you're right maybe they're like holy
[ __ ] we're trying to contain her because
she's about to explode ooh that'd be hot
too
you know like and all of which is
interesting but none of which is coming
from the show itself
that is all us watching the show which
and like we said last week i can't
fault the show for taking advantage of
the advantage that is
we are doing the work that nerds do
which is we invest ourselves in it we
theorize we have
our own versions of what this is and and
we're anticipating either being right or
wrong
but i kind of want the show to begin to
take ownership over itself in a way
and be the show it wants to be and not
the show i want it to be
and i'm not there yet like i'm still
watching
duh because of course i am but you know
the things that are happening so far
or like i might be as gratified
getting this information reading the
wikipedia entry
as to oh this is what happened this
episode okay
cool like i can read what happened and
lost
you know and sure you'll tell me that
the polar bears and there's weird fish
cakes and yeah and the dharma foundation
all this [ __ ]
but it's the characters that keep me
showing up we can make out and so far
the characters
are being so evasive as to not
allow me to sink my teeth into them so
i'm hoping that as we go forward i'm
hoping as
we get more of these little pokes in the
in
the facade we can then have the real
character begin to seep forward and
understand
what does wanda want you know what does
this version of vision want
what are the things getting in the way
of her wanting this you know what does
monaco want what does what did anybody
want
and and that's that's like job number
one of drama
is here's what your character wants
here's the 98 things between them and
getting it
and if they succeed then great if they
fail
also great but i got to know i got to
know that luke wants to get off that
planet
i gotta know he wants to be more than a
farm boy so that when he
does get to do those things it mean it
made it all
worthwhile without that if it's just
having a pretty good time being a farm
boy and [ __ ] happens to him
it's like oh well okay
the [ __ ] was fun but i'm not as i'm not
even convicted in it
um but yeah i'm gonna keep watching all
of that is like
not gonna like steer me away but it's
not yet
like oh wrote it um endorsement
it is you know weekly curiosity
you're a [ __ ] dream killer man just
just a [ __ ] dream killer um you know
that's you're
totally entitled turpin and in some ways
i'm like oh you're right but
my bar is much lower than yours and what
they gave me
in that final 10 minutes of the show not
even 10 probably seven
seven last seven minutes of the show was
enough for me to make me go i i agree
with you
i'm filling in more blanks i'm bringing
more information and providing more
information to the show than they are
currently providing
so i mean i hope to god i'm not
heartbroken by like but wait a second
that's not the show
that i thought i was watching but i'm
i'm happy to go
i'm it doesn't i don't bump into it i'm
not sitting there going like what the
[ __ ]
like it doesn't like you're absolutely
right about you know
what are what are their intentions what
do they want what i mean that's
generally
how one writes a program these cats
have the luxury since there have been an
ongoing program for 10 years now
of taking a very untraditional approach
at least at the top like it feels like
they're like look the gimmick will take
us
halfway there and then the real plot
could kick in and stuff and from what i
understand next week's episode is a
mind blower so i i love it to death but
you know me i [ __ ] love everything
but i did cry
every time i watched that [ __ ] scene
where she's like i
i was a twin i it [ __ ] like grabs me
in my heart
right away her the way her head [ __ ]
everything
about the delivery is just so [ __ ]
perfect and again it was the
excitement of the crack of like oh my
god here it comes
this is it like [ __ ] um however
hamstrike in uh
chat um echoed a thing that you kind of
said regarding loss but he said
wandavision isn't smart
it's a mystery box um it is a mystery
box
it could be smart as well um chipudi man
said the stork is mephisto thoughts
i mean okay
i mean i i saw them that made me very
excited i was like yes chipootie man it
is [ __ ] mephisto
she put the magic out of him and he just
flapped it away and in the comics
didn't mephisto take the twins like
because they were made
she formed the twins but they were made
up of energy or
aspects that turned out to belong to
mephisto so mephisto then absorbed the
[ __ ] twins come back to life in a
real
like you know uh [ __ ] uh horcrux
voldemort kind of way so maybe it's
maybe it is [ __ ] mephisto
and this the stork being a festival i
thought was a really good guess man
you should like okay
but i uh i
i can't a show can't be made entirely of
easter eggs
again for me especially if they're
marvel easter eggs oh my god
i'll eat eggs i can't because i'm a
vegan so these are the only eggs i can't
eat
ronald jones ronald jones says mark is
right kevin
listen to him
[Laughter]
um somebody i gotta find it again but it
was very cute somebody said
tony stork am i right i was like ah
maybe wouldn't that be weird
um let me see the real
catnip dave seb says the the major want
of wanda is trying to live a normal life
and she has really lost control of her
powers that is already
altering reality to as close as her
desires i mean i i believe me i love
reading everyone's theory but mark's
absolutely right
it's all of us going like i think this
is it
maybe kim k said mephistork
[Laughter]
that's hysterical um more man i think i
would i wouldn't feel
holy [ __ ] more more magga we have
somebody in our chat room called more
magga
more magga what are you nuts but anyway
more magga says
vegan oh no clerks 3 will take place in
whole foods
um i went vegan because i had a heart
attack bro i almost died so that's it
it's not a bougie thing it's like
life-saving thing
but whole foods would never let us shoot
inside that store it's owned by amazon
wake up be real
i find it's best not to insult these
people and just treat them logically
i think i also might feel better or
different about the show
if it dropped all at once yes you know
like if if
like the two-hour movie or three-hour
movie that it actually is
if you could just power through it and
then
it's the week to week to week the
drawing out of a thing that feels as if
it
should kind of be collapsed and
condensed anyway
um but yeah i don't know
it's just it's without being able to see
what's happening
it's hard to get invested in what's
happening the uh um
somebody asked a question that i was oh
ed powell matiere
says if this wasn't marvel would any of
us keep watching
excellent question you i mean i said it
last week if this wasn't marvel i
wouldn't have got past the first episode
i would it would have been like i don't
know what this is i don't know who these
people are
i and you haven't told me why i should
care yet
um you know i might have given it two
because it's well done
but i think after that second one like
tom sees that the last seven minutes
made it more like twilight zone
specifically it's a good life i agree
that's what i kind of i
i you know i just i want more of that i
want more of the like
you know [ __ ] wanda snap out of it
and [ __ ] and [ __ ] and
look the the fact that they [ __ ]
referenced ultron like just [ __ ] did
it for me man like i was like
that's you know honestly i can watch a
show full of [ __ ] easter eggs
like as long as they're all as tasty as
that one
[Laughter]
um in the chat uh neba said
what if the big bad is mojo and that's
why there's all the different
tv sitcoms which i thought was kind of
interesting
mojo from from like the new mutants mojo
yeah and that's why there's all the
different
tv sitcoms living in the
the tv world i guess that's possible
i don't think it's true but it'd be fun
uh mike
mike d who was in uh jane zomboberg
with the well yeah mike t you know he
was in the beast um
he he did the smoking jacket when i'm
like oh my smoker jacket in jane samba
reboot
he said geraldine wearing the fish pants
fish equals jesus
equals savior trying to save wanda
could you imagine if they were like that
like are the details that that's beyond
an easter egg that's like
telegraphing it very
you know for smart people only
do you think that's possible um i mean
when a show is operating at that level i
mean lost was doing a lot of that [ __ ] a
lot of deep [ __ ] cuts into like
you know same thing with like the matrix
so all of that [ __ ] like deep
philosophy
and you know the simulacrus somalacrum
and the nebuchadnezzar and all these
things mean something and if you read it
at that level then it all counts
um and hell sure they could absolutely
be making a jesus fish savior
um you know bumper sticker reference
here
and here for it if that's what it is um
but i don't know
i just don't know how awesome was it
when they went from full screen
to widescreen yeah when they were like
we're out of the show and now we're into
a movie we're into the marvel cinematic
universe [ __ ] oh that was dope
yeah it's a trick that um did you ever
see homecoming
that uh sam s mel show that was on usa
with um based on a podcast but starring
julia roberts who's in the first season
but they did a lot
[Music]
but they did a lot of you know work with
aspect ratios
as indicators of like both when and
where you are
and like if you saw this aspect ratio it
was this
if it was this it was another thing and
using that as a way to decode the story
is really really smart because by now
we're all paying attention to that [ __ ]
very closely and ever now everyone's
educated too like i remember in the
early 90s before i became a filmmaker
um vinnie pereira vincent prayer my
friend who worked at quick sub with me
um he wanted to be a filmmaker um he was
the first person i ever knew i was like
i'm gonna be a director i was like you
can't do that you gotta be born in
hollywood or something he's like no you
don't
um but he was the one um
oh [ __ ] i [ __ ] went down a hole and i
forgot what i said what were you just
saying
aspect ratios educated audience he was
the one that told me about aspect ratios
um
you know i remember being like um he
gave me a vhs
copy of a laser disc that he had copied
and it had black bars on the top and
bottom and [ __ ] proper aspect ratio
and this was at a time of course in the
early 90s everything was pan and scan on
video
full screen so he hands me that and i'm
like what the [ __ ] ben half the
picture's missing
and he's like no no no that's it's
proper aspect ratio half the picture is
missing the way you normally watch it
and [ __ ] like that
so you know i don't think everybody
you know like my mom's still in hip to
aspect ratio so i don't know if you
notice the screen change or something
like that but
most people have a rudimentary you know
kind of like oh yeah that's
like a movie and this is like tv
although now tv is widescreen as well so
the
the 166 frame doesn't really exist in
the world anymore except when you're
watching something on instagram i guess
yeah or like on your computer which also
isn't fully wide screen yet but like
you can't buy an old 166 tv they just
don't sell them
and so everything at this point is
widescreen but yeah i i spent a lot of
time in the wild
explaining to people no no no this is
more picture not less picture
why does it feel like a less picture it
just it just is
it's like it's science um all right man
so one division we'll be back
of course next week to talk about
episode four
and stuff but that for this week is our
one division
check-in update and stuff like that um
hopefully you all enjoyed now ladies and
gentlemen
we got a guest uh that's right he has
worked in marvel
he has worked at dc he has worked at
dark course he's comics
ladies he's worked his image he has
comics comics in his blood ladies and
gentlemen
we love these movies why because they
came from [ __ ] comic books man we
could never forget
the comic book part of this equation man
and tonight we have one of comic books
most wonderful greatest writers come
visit us man welcome to fat man beyond
the great jim krueger jim you there
hey i am how's it going so good man for
those that
uh are unaware you remember earth x
that's all jim well jim and the other
guy but
that's well let's break down
relationship because for some people who
don't follow comics we got a lot of
people in the audience and some just
don't follow comics at all
uh there's usually a relationship uh
sometimes you got an artist who is also
a writer but generally speaking there is
a writer of comics
and there's an artist on the comics who
did you work on earth x with jim
so earth x was me with alex ross
and john paulion alex did all the
designs
all the covers you know when i wrote a
script it went to alex for notes before
it even went to marvel
you know alex's blood was like he and i
have collaborated on so many things but
it was myself
alex and john paul leon
now take us back ma'am when did you
first get into comics as a kid
yeah yeah as as a kid so my dad had a
garage
he was an auto mechanic he had like four
or five
guys working for him and when i was like
five
six years old he would come home
you know have the lights swirling around
on the tow truck and he would take me on
toe jobs with him
and you know to to pay me
for like holding the rag while
he that he used while hooking up a car
or something like that he would always
have a couple comic books it would be
like doctor strange or
like jack kirby's commandy or or
something like that
and so there's this nostalgic thing
about comics too it's kind of
like rosebud almost i can't think of all
comics without thinking about
adventures with dad that's beautiful man
so did you know early on were you
cognizant of like
there's a writer and there's an artist
and were you like i want to be a writer
for comics
you know what i i didn't know anything i
i went into advertising
because i was good with puns or bad with
puns
depending on how people look at that and
um i got a job for an advertising agency
in sheboygan wisconsin as a junior
copywriter
won a bunch of awards for their annual
coho
fishing tournaments and
when that job lasted six months i was
like oh
is is another job going to last this
long and and all that kind of stuff
and so i did an advertising campaign on
myself and just started sending it to
marvel it was like every couple days
they got a different ad for me
you know like there'd be these cards
that would open up one of them
said you know um in the last six months
i've witnessed the beating witnessed a
beating
been held at gunpoint and found homeless
people living in my basement
um and then the car would open up and
say i think i'm ready for new york
and so there'd be like all these teasers
uh and then i said that my portfolio
which was a good portfolio and stuff
like that and so like
within three months of starting i was on
my way to marvel
so within three months of sending them
cards yeah sending them cards and
introducing myself
and that kind of thing and their
industry was growing
and you know what year is this around
uh i want to say this is like the mid
90s right around the time
when marvel was starting their own
distribution system
right around the time where all the
image guys left and marvel was like oh
no what are we gonna do now
like all that time um
you know it was a crazy time for marvel
what do you mean like i remember
do you remember there was like i think
it was a spec script that newline cinema
bought
back in the day when uh the guy would
send around
ticking boxes to every asian theme
studio
and it was for the ticking man with the
name of the of the spec script
and it was inside the box and like super
smart at a time when like
there's no real terrorism as far as we
know it and like
the script sold for a million dollars i
remember reading about it in in like
calling the reporter
but that sense of moxie of like [ __ ] it
i'll i'm just gonna keep hammering at
him with you know why i'm awesome and
you should hire me because i'm great
and uh and like that was i don't know if
that would work anymore
but [ __ ] it like seize the day well
and and the stuff i sent them was was
really like
funny and it was it was like marvel
appropriate the last one
said last card i sent them after they
got my portfolio
said i hear i'm i hear you're looking
for someone to write advertising you
know
and then the card opened up and just
hand written was advertising
am i hired oh my god like [ __ ] that's
a brilliant way in man
like you know of all the ways into the
industry you literally took your
your experience in advertising and
advertised yourself into a [ __ ] job
so marvel was the first comic book
company you worked for
right right and and at that point i was
just someone
working writing copy for them meeting
the editors and that was a crazy time
because
marketing above advertising had just
threatened all the editors saying you
know what if your books don't get
don't start selling the way they were
when you know rob
or jim or tom mcfarlane we're drawing
them
you're out so like it was this crazy
time where
where editorial hated marketing and
advertising because there were these
threats and
you know i was like coming in from
wisconsin being all nice and being like
ooh thanks for asking blah blah blah and
got
mocked continuously they're like [ __ ]
off milwaukee this is a new york city
that was it exactly and and it's also
like in a kid's mind and
when that kid becomes an adult i'm sure
you're like i'm going to marvel man it's
going to be
mary the merry marvel marching society
and you get in they're like
if you don't [ __ ] sell books
yeah no no i mean i think my favorite
story of that experience
was i remember walking in front of one
editors and this is
further into my career at marvel but i
remember
it was right at the point where earth x
got announced
i went by this guy's um office and he
didn't know i was on the outside i just
heard him hear that i was doing this
project and i just heard him go
[ __ ] jim krueger
and i kind of swore right then and there
that the next time i heard those three
words
i wanted to be like [ __ ] jim krueger
still haven't heard that yet but you
know i live in hope
what who did you deal with like at mar
when did you get your first
when you it sounds like when you got
there you didn't come as a comic book
writer did you start at another job and
then
moved to college yeah yeah i started as
as a copywriter like i was
writing all the house ads for books so
when you say house ads like we would you
write like what i read in the premier
catalog
yeah yeah or like you know how you'd be
going through a comic book and then
there'd be
an ad for another comic book that you
should be checking out
so i was you know like when you were
reading an issue of fantastic four you'd
come to that page that's
an ad for all the spider-man books and i
would write a headline that's like get
bitten by the bug
you know read spider-man every week like
stuff like that
how long did you do that before they
were like all right you can write a
script
um i think again it might have been like
three or four years i mean
what was really interesting is i i
started as a junior copywriter then
became their copywriter then senior
copywriter
ultimately became a creative director at
marvel before
uh bankruptcy like
got rid of our entire division but like
literally
like a month later i started writing
earth x but it was this continual thing
and what was great was
i got to do other things that never ex
like like there was a moment where
um aviarad came down and i had to do
this giant presentation
of all the movies that should become
marvel movies
so and that was the beginning of marvel
studios it was all avengers bass it was
all you do this you do this this looks
good on film
this looks good on film like all that
kind of which books which characters
which ip did you put forward
oh it was it was all building it from
avengers because they knew they couldn't
do anything with x-men or spider-man
so this and this is going way back yeah
this is going way back this is like
before even this is before
the hulk and iron man movies you know
well before i think those movies were
even coming out so i feel like
i have you know maybe my big
toe in the midst of you know that first
origin stories of the mcu yeah you were
there for the birth of it man
yeah so that was funny you did a lot of
time at marvel
but you've worked at dc as well what'd
you do with dc i know what you did to
see because we talked about right before
but
and this i want to talk about because
this sounds [ __ ] tremendous tell them
what you just did recently
oh are we talking about justice at dc or
are we talking about marvel's x which
was the prequel to earth x
well i was oh i'm sorry what i was with
that superman story
yeah the superman i jumped from marvel
over to dc because i wanted to hit that
superman story
yeah you've been working for what he
said as a
decade on a story man that writing right
there man
tell us about it well the idea is that
that i had an idea like
like when i think about the first comic
i was ever given
going back to my dad again it was this
trip to disney world that ended up
in the going in the midst of a hurricane
and my dad blowing my mind
blah blah blah but we took a train down
and
on the way both my brother who's younger
and i were given a comic book and my
brother was given
batman and i was given superman
and i remember as a six-year-old this
sense of disappointment because i wanted
the batman
so badly because batman batman was
badass and
that's that's never something we think
about superman
but like the more i've kind of grown
i've kind of come with this idea of what
i want superman to be and what i think
he should be
and why he kind of fails on certain
levels
and why even it seems like dc is always
scrambling to figure out a take
on superman so my big thing is like i
wanted superman to suffer
and not just like oh lois is in danger
or oh here's this magical substance
called kryptonite
how can i make superman suffer because
in superman's suffering
that he seems human or he seems
courageous
or anything like that so i finally after
like thinking about this idea for years
and
pitching it multiple times i finally
found someone who would buy it
because it's one of those stories that
was inside of me and i was like i have
to tell the story or figure out a way
so who was the one that bought it you
mean somebody at dc who was like yeah
someone in dc bought it
one of their editorial that that we're
looking for like
on the cover to the issue while i've
[ __ ] set it up kids
you're about to hear an idea for a
[ __ ] superman story
that they should they they can't now
because it would
require too much setup but they should
one day make this movie this
instantly captured my imagination man
tell them what the story is about jim
so the basic idea is that it's the story
of the green lantern
who's who the green lantern who was in
charge of protecting [ __ ] the planet
krypton
seeking out superman coming to him in
the in the name of
justice and mercy begging superman to
kill him
to end his suffering so good
so good for is that a full issue story
or one yeah it's a full issue story
it's like a 30-page story
you know it stands on its own but it
opened like even in the writing of it
like if the first section is him
discovering from being lost how to
um that that a kryptonian still survived
and coming here and then confessing
that it's because of him that billions
are dead
the second half of the story which then
propels it forward
is his remembering the last days of
of krypton those last moments of krypton
as
everyone is falling around him and all
that sort of thing to them the big bad
who's
who's our brainiac uh character
speculating on even why kryptonite
affects superman
and was so great is by going through
this and just asking questions
like i even have brainiac suggest that
the reason
superman's um is he's so afraid of
kryptonite
is because kryptonite like like
sometimes when you hear about haunted
house stories you hear about
how there are objects that still have
absorbed some of the cries and
things like every piece of kryptonite is
billions of cries out that it's absorbed
so when it's brought to superman
his hearing can hear all of them
and and it's it's a deafening thing that
brings him
to his knees and it's a constant
reminder that he wasn't there to save
them
that is [ __ ] fantastic and this green
lantern was
now and so who who is the artist
uh guy named neil edwards who's very
much like kind of brian hitch classic
classic superman style just visually
awesome and um you know he's also an
artist who worked on the steve aoki
comic book
i worked on last year you did a stevie
aoki yeah where with with tom bilyeu
and steve tom bill you and steve kind of
orchestrated and they had me come in and
find them a creative team and
all that sort of thing is all kind of
molded around the neon future
kind of brand of music that steve does
[ __ ]
but but it was it was cool to actually
go to one of steve's shows
and be in that you know be in his
you know upfront with him and him
constantly turning around and giving me
hugs
and looking at all these beautiful
people around
you know who looking at me and being
like
who's that guy so
he's a comic book writer yeah one of
these things
is not like the others one of these
things doesn't belong what is the book
um you've got some books that are out
now uh plug the books because one of
them
uh we were talking about before i was
like that's [ __ ] dope man
uh what is the talk about the books that
are available right now
uh i think the one you said was [ __ ]
dope is called the no ones
yes tell them that plot man so the idea
and then i'll tell you about my favorite
character on the team
too and that's this character right here
on the second issue the no ones
um the first issue if you see the little
dot after the o you know that's
like uh shortening the version of the
word number
almost it begins with this team of
celebrity superheroes they have their
own paparazzi they have their own action
figures their own show they have
everything
you could possibly imagine they're the
heroes of the world
and they accidentally while they're
fighting terrorists they
accidentally kill an innocent bystander
and they're so
afraid of what this will mean to their
bottom line
and their media and their shares and all
that kind of thing that they
they hide the body and they bury it in
secrets
um and then the next day they wake up
and no one's ever heard of them before
it's like they've been cursed to
insignificance there's you know they
don't have
their train that takes them their super
train or whatever that takes them
all around through new york because they
work through the tracks and all that
kind of thing
they have to take the path train to stop
a fire in new jersey
and on the train this lady looks at them
and says
what's your um you know why are you guys
dressed that way and they're like well
we're superheroes we're
these guys and blah blah blah and they
go through the entire explanation
only to have that page end with her
saying so why are you dressed like
that you know it's like people only
remember them for minutes they can't
even remind people of who they are
that's dope man and it splinters the
team so half the team sees as a way
to really reflect and change reality
like no no they can go into a bank they
can take money to fund
certain things or put money somewhere
and
reality will just like work around them
and the other half just wants their
um just wants their lives back and so it
creates this
battle between the two that that no one
will ever know
it's like um a mythic battle between
angels and demons
except none of these guys are angels hey
man who published
uh it's this it's a small company called
cave pictures publishing
but where can they get it amazon
yeah amazon or people can go to their
comic shop if they want it and order it
and you know i'm all
for talking to comic shops you know but
it's one of those things that people
really
like of mine those who have noticed it
and what else what are the other books
you got coming out
uh the trade paperback of marvel's x
just came
out which was alex and i getting a
chance to work together
and this was the prequel to earth x
which i
wrote at the beginning at the beginning
and part of last year
being like the end of 2019 and because
it's
all about the me this this pandemic
that gives people superhero powers and
mutates them
it turned out to be so prophetic of
the last year we've experienced you know
everything from
distrust for neighbors to fear of going
to grocery stores to what's it like to
be
taking over responsibility when your
parents are no longer there
you know like it deals with some pretty
heady stuff
well well for those who like we're
really into earth x
it answers a couple big questions for
them
mark i saw i kept interrupting you i
think no i mean i i just had one
question
like way way way back when but it's you
know i'm always fascinated by breaking
in stories
and and you got a pretty amazing one but
i i
in my travels it always seems as if
there's a big bar between the church and
state
of almost anything where like you know
how did you go from being
the advertising copywriter guy to
somebody that they would
allow or even listen to to pitch a comic
idea
because so often those two worlds don't
collide
yeah well you know i mean like one of my
favorite writers mark wade says that as
soon as you find a way
into the comic industry they shut it
down
um they close it up so i've heard there
are kind of three ways to do it
and and one is um
one is that you self-publish on your own
you put a book out there and then they
notice you and they want you to write
another is that you work in the industry
in some sort of capacity
and then can step over and the third one
is you have someone that that
kind of brings you in someone who's
already professional
and i kind of did all three
because even even before i was going to
college like i remember reading alan
moore's
swamp thing at the very beginning of
that run
and being so blown away it's like one of
the greatest things ever
especially those first 12 issues still
holds up and the anatomy lesson is one
of the greatest comic books ever written
never drawn
beautiful oh my gosh and i've i've been
working on my collection of those books
like i have
the first issue he wrote signed by him
and then the issue that has the demon
later on i've got that one signed by
kirby
it's like it's this special special
thing that i know was the beginning of
inspiring me
to even want to do this stuff but um to
you mark to to your question
i did that and you know what i really
feel like
at the same time you know i
i was writing scripts and taking them to
capital city comics in milwaukee and
madison
and letting them read my scripts for
other projects like
i was just constantly just making it
this fun thing i did
until it became a real thing
that's awesome the um
what you've worked for marvel for dc and
for image who else have you worked for
um i've worked for dark horse i've
worked for
um and dark horse was was the beginning
of my career that was
i did a book called foot soldiers which
is about these
three kids in a post-apocalyptic future
who go to the graveyard where all the
superheroes are buried and they rob the
graves
that's how they get their powers they
try to fill the actual shoes of the
original heroes
only discover how hard it is to like
fill those shoes
like dark horse was awesome i think i
even did
a um a thing for a claim back in the day
i think i've kind of worked for
practically everyone
who is the best to work for um you know
what i'd say that
everyone is awesome but
everyone has an element that's like a
job
you know and and so there's like oh i
have
oh okay you know i mean it's it's it's
funny because
you know i feel like like i'm getting to
do
a lot of like film and tv stuff now
and that's awesome but at the same time
like the egos of hollywood aren't any
different than the egos
of working in the comic book industry
it's like everyone's safeguarding their
ip
everyone's like no you can't do that but
sometimes
that's the best like like like most
notes
have been good for me i remember there
was a moment in earth x where i wanted
reed richards to wear professor x's
cerebral helmet
and the editor said no no that doesn't
work it only works
for professor x
and i was like oh i really need that in
the plot so
then i just you know i rewrote it in
such a way that reed had
a schematic of professor x's
brain um and was able to stretch
his brain to look like professor x's so
he could find out you know the secret of
the mutations on earth
and even the thing you know made made a
joke about
you know stretching stretching his mind
and stuff like that
going back to the puns you know good
that's a good piece of
[ __ ] writing right there the um
uh working with alex ross who is an
absolute
legend an icon and one of the greatest
talents not just in comics but
graphic talents on the planet ever do
you
do you have any do you like since you
worked with him on so many things do you
have any alex ross originals does he
ever just like here you go man just for
you
uh i do i do i have three pieces one
he um he gave me the cover
to the first issue of foot soldiers when
that came out from dark horse
which was so so special and um i mean
dark horse paid him his rate
and all but but i asked him because
we were already friends like my first
job at marvel um
was to go to gen con um one of the cons
and and to take him around and introduce
him to other people
as the artist on marvel's so it's like
our careers in the industry kind of
began together and while we were there
we just geeked out on on like kirby and
machine man
and all that kind of stuff but um to get
alex to do the cover for foot soldiers
i found him all the copies of grant
morrison and steve y'all zenith
from 2000 a.d which is probably
in my top five list of greatest comic
books ever done
so when you say you found it like you
secured them for them yeah yeah i found
them copies and set them copies
because it was like that was a point
where it was really hard to find british
comics
check you out man and then when you did
that he was like all right i'll draw it
yeah i was like okay well would you do
this and
i i was like i'll sweeten it by finding
you all the copies of zenith
charming um that was fun
is he um and when you were like it's one
thing to like uh
what so wait what are the three pieces
of art we got one is the the
what is the foot soldier's cover he told
you two is
i have um the cover to the first issue
of earth x
which is the bald captain america
sorry keeps i think it's too late for me
anyhow
but he wouldn't be bald if he'd gone to
keeps.com
you know you know you would hope
you would help that's like how big is
that piece he works large doesn't he
yeah he does it's it's like a really
really special piece i i don't even have
the courage
to put it in a frame and put it on the
wall i'm like oh no light will
what light will hit its you know uv
frame you'll be fine man yeah that
belongs in a museum what's the third
piece
and the third piece is from marvel's ex
because years ago
he took pictures of me um and
his design or his sketch of how peter
parker looks
in marvel's ex is me ah get out of here
man but it's me
it's me after keeps right
lustrous out of here that is dope
because for those that don't know alex
ross
like you know he does these incredible
paintings but he actually
has people friends model
for the characters like he's even
created outfits for them to wear
like there is a superman suit and stuff
like that and i've seen
like he's um he's
an absolute genius but he does work off
of life models more or less correct
yeah yeah he does in a lot of cases he
still has people come over
puts that puts them in the costume that
he's created for them
and we'll do photo shoots of them like
in his basement
or something like that like his place is
this museum like
i've never seen a room like his
action figure and comic room it's like
he has
four or maybe six life-size
mannequins with costumes that he's been
involved in making
in the center of the room as well as so
many other
other like treasures that's a comic
that's a comics fan right there and also
a guy who's like look
everything i got in this world is
because of comics and drawings so i'm
like of course he celebrates it and it's
totally
um all right man we gotta jump to the
news you got anything else you want to
say these cats where can they find what
was the superman book
number and name where can they get uh
it's adventures of superman
number 11. adventure superman number 11
so you can find it at your local comic
book shop yeah
you can't get out go find it on the dc
comics app or comicsology or something
like that
where you can get the no the number ones
the no ones
um you know you can get it at comic
shops you can get it on amazon
you can get it anywhere let me let me do
a quick plug for these two little indie
books
yeah only get either on amazon or from
me at a comic convention and since there
are no comic conventions right now it's
only amazon i have this
really dark fairy tale that's kind of
the heroic journey of the damsel in
distress
called the high cost of happily ever
after and
it's basically she gets married and it's
beautiful
and it's wonderful and then he goes to
war and goes down in battle and she
becomes a prisoner of the enemy and it's
about
how she as as this girl who was not born
into royalty
fights to be worthy of royalty even if
there's no way out
whoa and it's it's awesome and it's meta
and it goes in places
that people are always surprised girls
really like
it especially it's a gorgeous uh cover
who's the publisher
um it's uh sideshow media again
uh available on and also from sideshow
is the other thing i did which was again
a project i worked on forever and ever
and ever
it's called the runner and it's about
a guy who has um
been on the um he's been on the run from
the angel of death
since 1936 he's not getting any older
and he figures out how to keep ahead of
death
but part of that is almost a loss of
social humanity
and there's a day where a girl is going
to get killed right in front of him
and so to save his own butt
he saves her so of purely unheroic
reasons he saves her
and then she but death was supposed to
come to
for her that day so he's reawakened like
by teaching her how to run
two it reawakens kind of hero
like his own humanity and it's the
question of the things we run from but
there also have to be things we run to
and it's awesome like looking at all
right where do they get
show at what is the website uh sideshow
it's one of the sideshow medias
otherwise you know amazon is
where where you can find it or people
can you know
get in contact with me i'll send things
out
where can they get in contact with you
the best is uh
probably my instagram you know which is
just
i'm jim krueger i am j-i-m-k-r-u-e-g-e-r
uh that's probably the best way and in
the chat jeff
sartain said jim former picture framer
here
museum glass blocks 99 of uva
uvb and uvc find a good free
in the area and uh they'll be happy to
sell you
the expensive glass picture frames
protect art from damage
that's another voice telling you to
[ __ ] frame that
yeah that's good that's good uh
jim krueger absolute [ __ ] pleasure
man continued success
uh keep waving the flag for the for that
which you fell in love with in childhood
just like us same thing man comics
changed our lives
you have the most interesting road into
marvel though i've ever heard
i i didn't even even give get a chance
to tell you about my gunpoint story
and blah blah and all that sort of thing
but maybe different what's gunpoint
i i had a i was held at gunpoint in
madison wisconsin right before
i was like okay [ __ ] it i have to go for
marvel i have to go for it
um three guys three guys came to
my apartment pounded on the door
you know i thought they were just
looking for directions i when i looked
through the peephole i could only see
one
and all three pushed their way in
wanting wanting to
wanting drugs and money and ultimately
it's it's not the drugs
yeah i didn't even have money i i was i
i had a stereo
and it was a wedding present but it
wasn't a very good marriage so i did
offer them
that um
but they didn't want that and and
ultimately
it was two guys out in the hall with me
and one of them
ransacking through my stuff and the guy
had the gun but the guy said well
what's your name i said it's jim he said
no it's not it's bill and i said my id
is in there but i'm not going to go in
there to get it for you
and he said well you better do what we
say because pointing to the third guy he
has a gun
that guy pulled out the gun oh well i
said well let me see it
he pulls out the gun it's a
semi-automatic and
i'm thinking this is it this is
over at first i'm thinking because of
that wife i had at the time who had been
praying to god
to that i would die in a car accident i
was like oh my god
he's answering her prayer what kind of
god would do that
you know and you know ultimately the guy
ended up
running away because i thought i'm dying
and i said look
before you do that you should know god
loves you and the guy was like oh [ __ ]
he runs away and those other two guys
are in the apartment i start pounding on
neighbors doors to let me in
and a guy lets me into his apartment
whose name is bill
and i was like the irony of it all
made me start to see my life as a story
and i was like i need to start
telling i need to start approaching my
life as a story what's the next thing
what's the break into act two what's
what's gonna take me from this point to
this place and what's interesting is the
guys
who came that night stole my briefcase
and um you know broke it open later on
that night but i even got a call
later saying hey we found your briefcase
on the road blah blah
and it was filled with all my original
stories and all my original sketches
and things and characters that i used in
earth x and
batman stories and stuff like that you
got it all this stuff was
yeah all this stuff was restored to me
it was like
i needed i felt like i needed to pay
attention that was the most valuable
[ __ ] you had let's be honest
yeah totally and did your neighbor bill
say thank god they didn't knock on my
door because i got all your problems
i was like uh i want to get out of this
apartment really
really fast and you know the people who
ran the building said
well they're probably not going to come
back and i was like
i just called the cops and i was like
can you give me a note that i can give
to them and just
i need to move did you just so wait did
you really bust some god on them and be
like well god loves you
yeah yeah because i started thinking
about my mom's love
for things like quovatis and all those
old the robe and all those old religious
movies
and how she would talk about the the
christians going out into the
like lion pits singing before the lions
devoured them and i was just like
wow i'm gonna die
and so you invoked god i did but
i'm totally stealing that man i'm gonna
bust that move instead of pleading
i'm just gonna be if i'm ever [ __ ]
held at gunpoint i'm just gonna be like
well whatever you do just know that god
loves you jesus
even in that moment i was like wow what
do i really believe
what do i really believe it was like it
was like
this shot it was like a shot in the dark
it was like
the weakest faith immediately
imaginable being like well you know
maybe this will get me in
this will help god the guy's like whoa
and that's it yeah that's a [ __ ]
tight story man
and that makes you a better writer i'm
sure man you live through something like
that
[ __ ] yeah no no no well it just
i i feel like mostly it just made me
more aware
that we shouldn't waste time if we can
help it
amen living on borrowed time i felt that
way after the heart attack still feel
that way today
wise words from jim krueger man thank
you for [ __ ] getting that story in
that was tight and [ __ ]
indeed glad thanks thanks for letting me
be part of your thing today
no worries thanks for being here on
fatman beyond everyone give it up for
jim krueger go out and get jim's books
right now
i'm [ __ ] i'm reading that superman
book tonight that is tight man
i'm all for a [ __ ] suicidal green
lantern who like krypton
that is genius well and you know the
green the lantern
or or the ring won't let them kill
themselves
so he he picks a fight with superman
when superman says no
trying to get superman to ultimately
take him out
that's [ __ ] tight man that's that is
good [ __ ] right there i look forward it
uh jim krueger thank you for coming on
man be good
thank you thank you fun see you soon
logging in
thanks um [ __ ] man look at that
goddamn legend look how long he's been
working look at all the [ __ ] he's done
long-ass tale he's got i know i remember
running into the gym
when i worked at intermittent weekly
like i remember he came in with earth x
and this must be almost 15 years ago
and like so proud and so happy and so
just willing to talk about it and it's
like oh yeah [ __ ] yeah we'll put in the
magazine
and here we are now 15 years later still
both
still both kicking still both in the
industry still doing the work
um all right kids if you've just joined
us uh
we talked about wanda vision up at the
top of the show me and mark
uh to cover it in a siskel and ebert
kind of way
i was thumbs up and mark was trending
down
but it meant all the way um so uh
if you know when the show is all done if
you want to go back and watch that we
spent a lot of time on it but now
ladies and gentlemen is the exciting
part of the show because this
is where we get to find out our futures
this is where we find out
all the news that's fit to print about
this genre love we have
and everything that's coming to us in
the near future or things that have come
to us and happened and stuff
cut it short mark's going to give us the
news mark take us into the news
here's some news um did you
or do you have any desire for a willy
wonka prequel
movie because you're going to get one
if you want to get him this is a trick
question i'm getting it whether i want
it or not
you're getting it whether you want it or
not um warner brothers will be releasing
wonka on march 17th 2023
a prequel to roald dahl's charlie the
chocolate factory which most
focuses on the candy architect willy
wonka's younger days before
having his confection empire
um so it's willy wonka year one
yes the fourth the vaping powell just
roaming around the candy streets and a
[ __ ] turtleneck and a jacket
and he's like you know yes father i will
become a candy
after a [ __ ] i don't know a pack of
gum bursts through his window in the
night
yeah because just his dad just smacked
him in the face and says the candyman
again then i will dad i will
father i will become a candy man
um who will play the young willy wonka
and who's what's studio warner brothers
uh jc put up that graphic again so i can
grab a smoke
let's look at that roll doll artwork and
see if we can find any
clues go ahead mark who's making this
movie
warner brothers didn't make in the movie
uh there's no casting yet
but allegedly tom holland and timothy
chalamet
are being considered for the lead role
um oh
timothy chalamet well that makes if you
get that kid
then it makes sense because people love
that [ __ ] kid he was on snl recently
he was pretty funny he could pull off
some comedy
he was funny enough you know i
you know like it's fine either them
would be fine
i like them both doing what they do but
you know there's there's a version of
this where it's
why is it not sam rockwell why is it not
like
somebody like way more interesting
bring me back basically
there he is i just [ __ ] came a little
bit when you said why not sam rockwell
that is an awesome idea
sam rockwell as a young willy wonka then
would you be excited about this movie
i would get there i mean granted sarah
well is also younger
is older than than gene wilder was when
he played it
however i would still totally be down
for that or
i would be down for like donald glover
you know
like sure it doesn't fall into
continuity so you can't just walk all
three together and be like
why is this black man suddenly turned
white in these other movies
but i also don't care that much um
if i gotta have a dude who can sing who
feels like he has fun
who uh who's also like super [ __ ]
funny
give me donald glover give me lakeith
stanfield give me
you know give me janelle monae like
there's there's no reason to be as
adherent with this
as just find me a sort of sprightly
young white kid
so true carlos fontes said i want
lakeith stanfield to play the joker
i will take that as well what has he
been in that made you go like i would
love to see him as the joker
i've seen him in stuff but nothing that
i was ever like oh [ __ ]
um i mean he's he's great in everything
i've seen him he's great in get out he's
great
in um in knives out what's that other
movie where it's like
um i always forget the name of it it's
not thank you for calling but it's
it's telemarketers him and tessa
thompson was in it
yeah [ __ ] i can't remember the name of
that either but that's that's the one
that's the one where
he's a live wire and you know it seems
as if it's
it's all about this dude struggling to
maintain some sense of order in his
reality that's slowly slipping away um
but yeah i think he's i think he's great
and immensely talented
um so yeah i i mean sure
tom holland would be great timothy
chalamet would be great um i would not
be as interested in this movie as i am
were it not being directed by paul king
who made the paddington movies
which are among my favorite movies of
the last 10 years they're just so
[ __ ] charming and fun
um because yeah i don't necessarily need
a prequel to willy wonka like i don't
that's not a question i've ever had
which is how did he get this candy
fortune
that movie uh with a key standpoint it's
called sorry to bother you
sorry about it wonderful flick um i hate
to inform you mark that
santo valentino in chat um
has declared this a boring show
beyond boring yeah we [ __ ] let santo
valentino down you better [ __ ] pick
it up mark
because when you lose santo there goes
the internet
as goes santo so goes the internet
absolutely
santo valentino and not having this show
he says is [ __ ] boring so
maybe we'll light some [ __ ] on fire try
to keep it interesting um all right so
we're getting willy wonka a young willy
wonka willy wonka year one
yeah three years in the right hands
maybe it'll be some
fun sure what up next
remember how we were getting a four hour
uh
tv series of the justice league
zach steiner cut yeah there were four
separate
episodes yeah not anymore apparently
now it's just a big movie i'll take that
i can i can make them episodes on my own
i just have to pause and go to the
bathroom and stuff like that but
i'm i think i'm more into the idea of a
four-hour movie
uh than i am yeah i mean yeah because i
could watch it at my pace and stuff
you know he made a movie he didn't make
a tv show
so breaking it up into like four
separate episodes
you know i i i'm i'm for it man i i'm
before being one four hour chunk i mean
look
i'm gonna watch all four episodes back
to back to back anyway i'm gonna binge
the [ __ ] thing so
might as well just sit down commit grab
myself like a fistful of [ __ ] weed
and [ __ ] and just sit there for four
hours being like
this is better you know well
tell me something i will i'll tell you
[ __ ] anything
i'm gonna keep this show exciting for
[ __ ] santo valentino i'll tell you
that much
santo my friend i'm gonna ask kevin a
question can you roll with me
um what's the longest movie you've ever
seen
i'll bet you it didn't hit four hours it
did not
but you fair well what titanic's like
three hours right
titanic is three hours godfather
godfather two
those are all like in the two and when
you're watching and when you watch
remember back in the day they put on vhs
the godfather epic which was the two
movies [ __ ] together
that was definitely over four hours i
could do it i could do four hours
standing on my head for
for justice league particularly if we're
gonna see some [ __ ] we've never seen
before and whatnot and
i am so committed to seeing this dude's
vision like you know
zach had a thing he was trying to do and
then it got
you know [ __ ] changed and stuff so
i'm i'm here for it man like this is a
it's a big moment for him but it's also
like kind of a big moment
for like filmmakers in general
particularly filmmakers
like myself um and usually not zack
snyder
who have experienced like a lack of
success
uh with their movies from time to time
or being you know having the
rest of the world be like this sucks to
get a second bite at the apple like this
and to do it exactly the way you want
where like it seems like he's dictating
the terms where he's like
no i don't want to do single episodes
now i want to do is a four-hour epic and
stuff
you know it's it's it's uh it's cool
like i you know i don't think there's
any
snyder cuts in my future there's a very
long cut of jersey girl which recently
um
paramount like took over the miramax i
guess they've got most of the library
and stuff
so they were talking about like hey we
want to put out like a jersey girl this
year and i was like well i have
the extended cut which i've showed at
vogueathon and stuff
and i want if if they allow me to i want
to call that
jersey girl colon the snyder cut because
that term now just covers so much ground
man
it it tells the story of yes this
filmmaker is going to get to go back
and you know [ __ ] fine tune and make
the exact
movie they want to make so i'm okay with
it being four hours man but again if you
don't want to watch four hours just
pause it and watch like an hour a day or
something
i i think the only way that you can do
jersey girl the snyder cut
is if the trailer trailer's in black and
white with hallelujah playing over
you better believe it right at the top
man
you get some [ __ ] cohen in that in
that [ __ ] right up
right up top set the mood yeah the tone
[ __ ] i mean my only my only worry about
a four-hour cut
of anything hemorrhoid is that
structurally it's hard to you know
if he wasn't designed to be four hours
long and like the longest movie that
i've ever seen that was great
was lawrence of arabia that's like 3 45
and like what
um i just i saw in chat and i was i was
gonna
because we mentioned the godfather
maurice the beast said any love
for the godfather three coda movie did
you happen to watch that by any chance
i didn't no i was curious but not that
curious
i did i did one night we watched it and
um
it was it was interesting i prefer the
theatrical
cut there was literally an ending to
that movie
this one like spoilers
they don't show them dying remember at
the end of godfather three [ __ ] just
dies in the chair
they don't do that in this um they
reordered some [ __ ]
at the top a little bit to set it up
kind of better i guess but i i didn't
you know i
i i thought it was enjoyable to watch
but i did not think like
thank god he did this you know i i but i
was not a big hater on godfather three i
did like
you know it's it's before we had marvel
movies i loved an interconnected [ __ ]
universe and any [ __ ]
movie franchise and godfather three you
know whether you like it or not
it's part of a universe the characters
are coming back so forth and so on and i
personally didn't think
homegirl was that bad at all like
everyone always kind of goes after
sophia coppola i think she's fine in the
movie there's a few lines that i would
have been like she would have been
better served if they were trimmed
but i thought she was totally good in
the movie particularly for how young she
was and inexperienced and [ __ ]
so i enjoyed the coda but not honestly
not as much as i enjoyed
godfather three i'm not saying it's a
worse movie but i didn't think
the changes particularly to the end
really didn't do that
much for me up top i guess it helped
clarity and stuff but
it's his movie he gets to do whatever
the [ __ ] he wants and he
called it something else like a long
title
like it used to be the godfather part
three or something
and now it's got the godfather coda
colon something something you know
michael or leonie or something yeah like
a really long title but it was it was
worth the watch
if you remotely liked those movies um
just to see what he did but it was
interesting somebody brought that up man
i was like oh my god i did watch that
and for you i how did you feel about
three the first time it happened
um you know like i i i think that
it's fine you know like uh you know is
she is sophia coppola a great actress no
has she ever been a great actress no not
really
hold on i gotta stop because we got an
update
huge important update mark who's this
from
from santo valentino and it goes back
santo's back to set a straight he goes
one division is boring kevin not you
guys and he gave me a rolled eye emoji
and a big heart
i mean i wasn't gonna sleep well if i
thought we lost santa
tell you something man that's the third
act twist that this boring ass [ __ ]
show was missing
that santo loves us don't like wanda
vision i'm okay with that
you're in mark's camp santo but me i'm
just happy to know that you're here for
us man i was like what were we doing
boring
i was like i thought jim krueger was
fascinating that superman story
was legit wonderful where i'm like
somebody needs to do that as a [ __ ]
movie man that's tight
in a world where they're doing that
green lantern series that should be one
of the episodes because that's like
[ __ ] nuts man like i would love to
see
like a one-hour episode about the
suicidal green lantern who let krypton
die
that's [ __ ] cool yeah look at my
[ __ ] face
um in any event thank you santo sansa is
a good guy everyone's like yay santo
godfather iii i didn't care enough about
it the first time to
contemplate revisiting at this time also
because i don't know if i could know
what's different
you know like i would have had to watch
it again twice to be able to appreciate
it and
that all seemed like a waste of time
when i could be watching the great
british baking show
again and again it again is that what
you're deep diving on now
well now i'm in the great american
baking show holiday editions because i
just literally
need brits being nice to people when
they cook
like so bad um i've been watching
did you have you watched snow piercer
no is it good i like here
if we've all seen well i'm not gonna say
we've all seen but i assume most people
have seen
um snow piercer but how do you say the
guy's name
um the guy who did uh
paris what was it parasite um
is it ho i thought so but i can't
believe
um i'm sure somebody in chat will put it
up there man um
uh snow piercer the [ __ ] movie was
wonderful it's about a [ __ ] train
that um i'm waiting for somebody to put
put his the director's name um
yeah long to know there it is all right
mark got it well done
um and as a director i should [ __ ]
know and that boy does that just make me
feel like an american
and a white guy all at once may have
helped make hope
um bong joon ho's movie um
it has chris as captain america and
chris evans and stuff
and it's about this [ __ ] train like
the earth is frozen
and it's a train of like you know in the
tv show they're like 1001 cars i don't
know if that was the same in the movie
but it's this long ass [ __ ] train
that never [ __ ] stops
and you know because outside the world
has been frozen because
mankind did it and [ __ ] like that so the
train has all sorts of levels of
first-class people
and second class third class and then
like some people like who
weren't supposed to get on the train um
stowaways got on the [ __ ] train and
they're called tailees they live in the
back and [ __ ]
like they live like in almost like
kind of tenement housing on the train or
something like that and so the movie was
about how the guys in the back the
people in the back
trying to get up front and chris uh
evans being the hero he finally gets up
front to find
you know mr wilford the [ __ ] guy who
runs the train and [ __ ] like that
fantastic [ __ ] movie if you haven't
seen snow piercer
do yourself a favor go watch it like
immediately but knowing this audience
we've all seen scope pearson but
if you haven't seen the show [ __ ] go
check it out man
they found a way to stretch this [ __ ]
out into a [ __ ] show man and the way
they did it was by turning it into a
murder mystery
like right off the [ __ ] top and david
diggs
like he plays a guy who was a cop in the
real world a detective before everything
went to hell and [ __ ]
he was one of the people that stowed
away on the train
um so he's a tailey and like in the
movie
like he's not he ain't playing chris
evans character but in the movie like
chris evans leading a
revolution to get to the front of the
train and [ __ ] he's like the figurehead
and whatnot
and it's the same kind of thing here the
same kind of setup it's not a sequel to
the movie it feels like they're just
doing
their own take on the film kind of like
match or something like that but i
thought it was a prequel
because the movie does set up that there
have been revolutions in the past
they having watched the show for now
i've seen almost all of season one
there's no like reference to hey
remember when this happened once before
they the way i felt and maybe i'm wrong
maybe someone in chat will tell me
is it feels like they're just doing
a show based on the idea but not a
sequel show or anything like
that i think i could be wrong and stuff
um what platform
bear bear gordon asks i watched it on uh
i think it
i watched on hbo max but it's not on hbo
max it's on another channel
is it so is that in the warner brothers
family would that make sense
so i watched it on hbo max but if not
you can see it on tnt
david diggs plays a detective and just
when he's about to leave the revolution
he gets pulled up to the front of the
train
to solve a murder and so like you know
just when you're like well i know where
it's going you're like oh [ __ ] and
as a person who appreciates media and
this person appreciates
trying to write a series now and stuff
like that i thought it was incredibly
clever how it's like
they they could keep this going for for
a while and it's no less [ __ ] bloody
than the movie
like people fight with hatchets and [ __ ]
like that um
there's there's not i wouldn't there's
not nudity per se but like you know
there's lots of like these people are in
bed and they're literally not wearing
clothes
and these people are getting showered
and they're literally not wearing
clothes you don't see
the close-up on any bits but that's all
me a long way of saying like it feels
more grown up like i don't know how they
rate tv programs anymore but like
i'm pretty sure i heard somebody say
[ __ ] a couple times
so if it's on tnt man tnt is just like
we give up
go ahead curse first
basic cable has kind of just abandoned
any hope
and pretense towards being like we're
network now we're cable
um carl cox says wait till you get
to the end of snow piercer kev it very
well
could be a sequel they said there was a
revolution before in the first episode
it is based on the book that's true
it's based on a french book or a french
comic book or something
what is it friends pierciage you know
the book you've heard of it
i've heard of it yeah like i remember
when the movie first came out and
everybody was like no it's based on this
sort of legendary french comic book
that's been around her forever and ever
um jennifer conley is on the show and
like
her like she is for all intense purposes
the lead
um and she really like holds it together
and she
yeah i don't wanna her character is
very interesting mark um it's seen in
the trailers that sean beamon shows up
for season two
apparently apparently i read that online
and [ __ ] like that
and when sean bean shows up he only
shows up to die so i expect he'll
[ __ ]
die in this show just like he's died on
every [ __ ] show where i've invested
in him where i'm like
hey it's sean beat and sean bean's dead
walk onto a train they've got yes
they've got
um they've got a season two i guess
starting fairly soon or something like
that but i've just been because season
two is beginning because they said sean
bean i was like
i'll go [ __ ] watch some season one
and i really i dug it i
honestly i was like incredibly impressed
as a writer that they were like yes
it's everything you remember but in
order to make this thing go longer
we need to do things like and so we're
telling our version of the story
um no less satisfying you know if the
other one's any more satisfying it's
because you're out in two hours and [ __ ]
but this i've enjoyed the ride pun
intended
um so far man and just the notion it's
such a real [ __ ] cool sci-fi notion
like
we're on a [ __ ] train that can't stop
and we're surrounded by ice and death
it's like that's so metal um anyway what
other news we got
uh we got some quick hits we're not
going to be late with these too long
um robert kirkman's invincible cartoon
on amazon uh
i love robert kirkman as a human being i
love him as an artist as well as a
writer of course
um but i i love him uh as a human being
he's such a [ __ ] good guy man
uh when does this show begin uh the
first three episodes of season
one will premiere on amazon on march
26th
with new episodes every friday after um
on friday it's culminating in the season
finale on april 30th
uh prime man it's on prime i look
forward to watching it the animation
looks great reminds me of
the stuff that we're doing over on uh
motu on masters the universe
um and the voice cast is [ __ ] bonkers
i mean what is that
stephen young is the lead uh mark
grayson jk simmons is his dad
um oh seth rogen jillian
jacobs andrew reynolds zazzy bates mark
hamill walton goggins jason manzoukis
may whittman kevin michael richardson
yeah it's [ __ ] nuts oh my god we also
have mark hamill and kevin michael
richardson in our show
ooh nice voice but i believe seth's also
a producer isn't he
um i'm not sure i don't i don't think so
it's not a it's not a point grey jam
it's a sky-bound and uh circle of
concepts
they may be are they maybe doing the
feature version of it they
they were involved in a feature version
of it which i'm not sure if it's still
happening or not happening but
um and for all now he might very well be
also a producer on it because seth rogen
has lots of fingers and lots of pies
uh he is he's doing his career right man
oh is he [ __ ]
writing for himself and writing funny
[ __ ] for himself but he's getting sure
he's making sure the cool [ __ ] gets made
like you know whether it's or not he's
there to get it made he's just using his
power to like [ __ ] like oh this would
be a cool thing
and uh rightfully so um he's a patron
saint
of these bars he does not get enough
credit for that
we now have geeks who can be that person
for a long time it was like
martin scorsese presents and like david
lynch has found this guy he's putting
out a movie like
there had always been filmmakers who
helped kind of bring in
sort of the next generation or other
voices you haven't heard before
but rarely do you get that in the geek
space um but it's nice that they're now
some [ __ ] big swinging dicks who are
also nerds who can get [ __ ] done
amen michael ferdinand in chat said
tomorrow night on tnt
is season two of uh snow piercer
um and then he said mark that's your
homework for the week watch snow piercer
season one so we could all talk about
season two episode one
and one division episode four next
saturday michael ferdinand [ __ ]
giving you the business man telling you
what you're doing
jesus birdman's bulletin
bullish that was awesome all right what
else you got
uh titans which is now on hbo max after
having migrated from the dc universe app
has cast its oracle um
they've got their barbara gordon there's
an actress named savannah welch who will
play the iconic hebrew seder in the
upcoming third season of the dc show
um she is i'm sorry go ahead
is it going to be batgirl or just
barbara gordon
um but it seems that by casting this
actress who uh who herself is an amputee
who lost one of her legs in an accident
in 2016.
it feels like we're getting legit oracle
we're getting barbara gordon
that's wonderful man that's awesome and
how cool the role was somebody
who was like in a wheelchair yeah i mean
she's she's an actress
and she's like been doing fight training
there's some quotes she put on instagram
saying
i always dreamed of getting to do stunt
work when i had both legs but in 15 plus
years of acting i never had the chance
to
until now that's awesome man what a ray
of sunshine she is
um and she joins what is the titans
season three exciting season three
which uh which i guess is beginning
production relatively soon
on that show dude i'm woefully remiss i
have not watched titans um
is dick and starfire coriander are they
in a relationship
i don't know i too am woefully remiss in
my titan's viewing
in that i saw the [ __ ] batman pilot but
that's about it i remember that
[ __ ] batman um what a way to start a
show
um yeah i well babs joining the show
might mean love triangle if if he is
already involved
you know because that's two people he's
dated in the comics right corey
which is perfect for drama look at all
these ladies
that's how they make a tv show isn't it
um good for her man i look forward to
babs gordon joining
the uh show that i've yet to watch i
will watch that show one day
mark my words indeed uh speaking of the
dc universe app which
no longer exists as a streaming uh
content deliverer
the way it was initially uh sort of
envisioned
it has now shifted to be entirely as a
comic book
app um as of god
last week the 21st it will be devoid of
all original tv content and now
exist as dc universe infinite which is a
premium digital comic book service and
community hosting the largest collection
of dc comics
online so can they read
jim superman there you think um it's
entirely possible i mean
i i don't know what exactly their
rollout strategy is for their digital
stuff i'm sure that book is also on
comixology
but if if if i'm dc and i'm launching a
dc universe.com
app thing for 7.99 a month or 74.99 a
year
um i would have every dc comic that's
available anyplace else
up on it otherwise why would i pay that
money for it
um that is uh i loved the dc universe
but you know now hbo max kind of
functions
you know in a much bigger way for the dc
universe gets more eyeballs and stuff
like that
i think turning it into a comics app is
smart they're a comic book company makes
absolute sense
good for them andrew chambers on on chat
said netflix is dropping a movie a week
you guys should do a weekly movie review
show
i care a lot the movie that stars
rosalind rosamond pike and peter
dinklage
he said looks amazing i did see a
trailer for that movie and that does
look really
good um we'll try i mean look i tend
like all of you like at night i [ __ ]
surf through every app going like give
me something new um what i'm enjoying
right now is search party season four
did you ever watch search party mode i
never did i hear great things about it
[ __ ] fantastic like wonderful
performances
twists and turns great piece of writing
wonderful [ __ ] show
season four has been uh equally as
enjoyable and stuff so
um yeah i i tend to go surfing so i i'm
sure we'll i will watch
i care a lot i don't know if we're going
to turn it into a weekly
bit of like here's what happened on
netflix but you know i'll
totally let you know when i [ __ ]
watch something pretty sure i mean
unless netflix decides
to be a sponsor in which case hey this
is what we watched this week on netflix
give us some of that [ __ ] david spade
after show money man
[ __ ] i'll talk about netflix i'll say
anything about whatever they got on here
um what else we got um now we have you
know a little bit of sadness
sadly said wait before we get the
sadness should we talk about the
superman trailer we can't show it
obviously because every time we show
media
uh from youtube we get [ __ ]
slaughtered and [ __ ] so superman and
lois
awkward title but whatever um put up a
trailer this week and i'll be honest
with you
like you know i was like right on
superman show um
but this trailer was the first thing
that made me go like
superman show you have my attention um
it is
nothing like i thought it would be
have you seen the trailer yet um i did
see the trailer
you know i'm i'm i'm always
a little um tentative when it comes to
pilots
and and their look only because 99
of the time uh it's a network will spend
more on a pilot than they will on the
rest of the show
um and so they might have just shot the
[ __ ] works on the pilot and it looks
fantastic
and i'm like oh yeah no i'd be curious
about this now will every other episode
also look like this
you know do they all get to look a bit
like you know [ __ ] man of steel
or will they all start to look a bit
like supergirl not that supergirl look
bad
but the the the swinging quality um
of you know cinematography and the
amount of time you get to spend it's all
about money
and you know i if the writing is good
the writing will likely stay good
but i'm not sure if you can sustain that
level of look
on a network show for that long but much
like you said
you had my curiosity now you have my
attention patrick betts
uh wrote cw dot dot dot you know meaning
like cw
but i think from the look of the trailer
they're spending more money on this than
they do on the normal cw
show and i think that has a lot to do
with like will it also
do the cw shows wind up on hbo max or no
um they historically don't only because
the deals have been made for the
berlanti versus the cw for their shows
to migrate to netflix first
and so at the moment i don't believe
flash or arrow or supergirl
or or legends or black lightning or on
hbo max
um i just made a deal with superman
where they're like
it's going to be on cw and then go to
hbmx like they do with
well i mean titans used to be on dc
universe and then go to
hbo max and now i guess it's just hbo
max right
so yeah i mean they might have made a
separate uh you know above and beyond
deal
for this so that it gets to be a big
driver on hbo max and so they're
spending more on it
um that would be great for them and i
think great for an audience to be able
to have a
high-end totally lustrous version of
this
you know and now that you know supergirl
is entering its final season
like they gotta have somebody to
represent that ass
so walk that ass um work that ass
fabia fabian santos says hbo max
is behind it too i was gonna say it
looks like they spent
like a little more scratch on this show
and it would stand to reason if it was
cw
and hbo max um
langley neely said i was excited by the
new superman low show when it was an hbo
max show
it and star girl moving to cw worries
the hell out of me
it's going to max instead of netflix i
i mean have you watched star girl yet
well when we talked to breck messenger
back in the day i watched the the first
couple
yeah i'm halfway through it's [ __ ]
charming and delightful and it
absolutely belongs on cw it fits
perfectly on the cw
um all right what else we got
um a couple of rips sadly hold on hold
on a big shout out from dursamell
in the chat he says wait this is live
holy cow i finally see you guys live
much love from romania where it's 6 26
am wow romanians watching the show mark
romanians now
that's a dude who spent a little too
much time up late drinking that dragon's
tears
no doubt man i'm all right sorry what
were you saying
meera ferland a croatian actress who
played
the minbari ambassador delane on babylon
5
and the french researcher danielle
rousseau
on abc's lost has passed away she was 65
years old
she died in her home in los angeles from
complications from the west nile virus
which yeah all the viruses one could
catch these days she caught west nile
yeah could you imagine you [ __ ] dodge
covid but you get the west nile
it's a shame i remember from lost i
didn't i wasn't i didn't watch babylon
five but i
remember from the she was first season
of lost right maybe season one or two
um she was sort of recurring and i think
she she did sort of scatter throughout
um i i did not watch all of babylon five
babylon five premiered
very close to deep space nine and it was
like you get to choose your space
station show very few
it was like the beatles of the rolling
stones like you gotta choose one
and i chose deep space nine um but she
was on 111 episodes over all five
seasons of that show and uh j michael
jaczynski who was the creator and wrote
almost every episode
um paid tribute to her fiery and
fearless side
that fought ceaselessly for her art
so yes she will definitely be missed in
in lots of different fan communities
um some of which definitely intersect
and overlap
a lot of love for her in the chat and uh
matthew
rickiana wrote too classy for covin
very
the other the other big notable um
passing of the
of the weekend you know the week was
larry king
the the self-made man from brooklyn who
spent six
decades on cnn and elsewhere as an
interview on the radio
and on the television passed away at 87
years old
radio tv and digital man look at those
two old men i look
older than him in that picture um yeah
he was i put up a tweet and instagram
about it today
my dad would always be like did you see
he was on larry king last night
and then one day i got to be on my king
oh man's dead but he would have been
like
how the [ __ ] did you get on larry king
last night
um i i met him wonderful guy man and
like his uh
story is inspiring because he did
[ __ ] pull himself up from nowhere
he's not born to anything and stuff
i just read a wonderful tweet string
from um uh what is it the uh the
lady who does the actress who does the
voice for she-ra on the netflix show
um whose name escapes me but i unrolled
the thread
and she talked about when she worked in
beverly hills at a restaurant how
larry king would come in every thursday
and [ __ ] and order almost the same thing
and he was always looking for the
perfect bagel
yes complaining about like you know the
bagels out here suck and [ __ ] he's right
there's something to do with the water
back east that makes the bagels the way
they are in the water out west
ain't the same water so the bagels out
here aren't quite the same unless
you have water trucked in from back east
and there's some places that do that
larry on the other hand open to [ __ ]
his own bagel joint the brooklyn
water bagel company i believe it's
called which i've been to and have
bagels wonderful
he has a giant machine or right in the
window that
takes los angeles water adds the
minerals and [ __ ] from new york water so
that they're making their bagels with
new york water like this was very
important to him
there's a mobster yelling at the water
just [ __ ] change
be better um
what a legend what an icon what a
broadcaster
um not just radio and television but
digital as well he [ __ ]
joined us in the digital future as well
and then never to be
stopped speaking even when like he was i
don't know what happened cnn i guess
they were like we're done
but he kept [ __ ] interviewing people
man and like interviewed
a thousand more people thousands of more
people after
he left cnn where he interviewed people
for decades and stuff
uh what an amazing career one amazing
man and stuff how old was he 87
87 years old um he'd had covid
um over the winter um well we're still
in the winter i think i guess the
towards the end of last year um but
there the cause of death was not
specified
so who knows but yeah it's it's it's a
vast
uh and very impressive legacy um and had
been in some movies and tv shows because
he became
such a personality that that absolutely
like they would
they would nod on him for shows like
murphy brown and american crime story
and
movies like uh the long kids good night
and primary colors
and dave which we we were talking about
before we started to roll
and he's the voice of a lady dragon
in all of the shrek movies so he does oh
i didn't know you you told me that and i
was like
he was and he was swimming to the geek
he does man he was in ghostbusters he
legitimized ghostbusters you know him
and casey
made it real it's like i hear those
people every [ __ ] day and they're
talking about ghostbusters
as a kid that was magical man um
rated milk points out in chat that comic
book artist
steve little died this week as well
um i saw a story about that he he was
very active i think in the 80s and 90s
if i'm correct um he passed away we miss
him anybody that lends to this art form
um you know we doff our cap too and
you've got to remember
steve little probably draws drew
somebody's absolute
favorite comic book in this world like
the same way that jim krueger was
talking about the books he loved as a
kid and when
i'm sure there are people out there who
are like without
this book i wouldn't be who i am today
or whatnot he was the artist behind some
of those books so
sad to see him go
um finally there's there's a great post
up on instagram from brian k vaughn
who uh who's offering a look at an
unpublished alan moore script
for a price um as his post reads
recently legendary comics creator bob
wyachek
who uh inked some of my favorite comic
images ever including the cover to
uncanny x-men 210
uh easily the most badass thing my 10
year old self ever seen has been dealing
with some costly health issues
inter-editor extraordinaire dunber who
offered to help raise some funds for bob
by auctioning off the only existing
script of an unpublished gen
13 annual by our greatest living writer
alan moore
with moore's generous permission of
course and guess which aging fan by
aging fanboy used some of his ill-gotten
hollywood blood money to acquire this
important piece of comics history
the unfinished story still over 35 pages
long is a sharp
surreal satire of x-men teen titans in
the entire industry of that era
and more puts puts more thought into
each of his panel descriptions than most
of us put into entire stories
anyway rather than hoarding this lost
treasure in his vault i thought i would
share it with you
share it with those of you who are kind
enough to donate any amount to bob wyatt
chick's gofundme page which is gofundme
dot com slash
f slash bob wyatt check sorry slash
bob hyphen wyatt check hyphen glaucoma
hyphen relief hyphen fun
please just forward your donation
receipt to this email thanks for helping
bobw
gmail.com and he will uh eventually send
you back a private link to a scan of the
script for your personal reading
pleasure
thanks so much for doing whatever you
can to help and i hope everyone is
staying safe and sane out there
so if you donate a buck or more
he'll send you a pdf of an alan moore
script that nobody's ever seen before
it's pretty damn sweet man that's nice
um a lot of people in the chat are
reminding us that uh
they said he's not genre but hank aaron
passed away as well
um i believe he is a sports figure if i
remember correctly
he is indeed he is um among other things
the home run king of baseball but also
the last player to be called from the
negro leagues into the major leagues
oh is that right wow so baseball history
aside from baseball history
indeed um i wow it just reminds me of
how not a sports person i
am but um how so sad to see him go as
well
a lot of people seem to like him because
they're all in the chat talking about
what about hank aaron
and then uh the chewbacca in in uh
in the in the comment section said
director walter bernstein died today
um i'm not sure who that is but you know
anytime a director dies
it just brings me that much closer to it
so i don't want to see any directors die
because if all directors live forever
i'm a director here we go
um that's the news my friend that's all
the news
that's all the news i've got a little
bit of news a lot of people have been
asking about
uh you know uh masters universe
like when we gonna have information
about masters of the universe on netflix
um there might be something this week
[Music]
might be something just saying just
throwing it out there
into the world um all right we're
over two hours into the show ladies and
gentlemen um hopefully everyone's
enjoying their saturday evenings and
stuff
uh we've come to that part of the show
where
you get to talk where you
have your say uh but jc is your voice
uh it's the q a portion of the show jc
proprietor of uh scum and villainy
cantina
where we always do this show except now
of course in the
midst of a horrible pandemic where the
la numbers are terrible
uh what has been going on in chat this
evening jc
um typical typical
chat night pretty good uh pretty good
crowd
not uh we had a lot of people point out
that um the return of the king extended
edition
from lord of the rings is also over four
hours long
uh and i couldn't help but notice mark
complaining about the four-hour snyder
verse
uh justice league movie but he's also
the same person who sat
in the uncomfortable el capitan
theater for 24 hours watching every
marvel movie in a row
so uh actions speak louder than words i
well that's that was 18 two-hour movies
sith princess 11 38 says what about the
godzilla versus kong trailer supposedly
coming tomorrow that's absolutely right
they're going to drop the trailer
for godzilla vs kong tomorrow ladies and
gentlemen so
get ready for that they've dropped
teaser images the poster which they
released this week looks really [ __ ]
cool
and this is another movie that we're
going to be able to watch on hbmx if we
got hbo max that correct
indeed you know they warner brothers
solve their issues with legendary who
was
furious after having put up 75 of that
budget
and couldn't recoup any of it you know
internationally this is how this is how
they solved the problem mark they were
like
okay fair enough we got it
you know and and yes there are theaters
that will be open overseas but their
issue is always
guys once you put it on the [ __ ] hbo
max somebody will pirate it and then it
becomes not
entirely valueless but the the valuation
diminishes
drastically um so but yes
they've been made whole and so now we'll
see it and if you live in a place where
theaters are open or in a place
hopefully
la might get there by march where you
might be able to rent yourself a theater
i will happily spend the money to sit in
an actual movie theater
and watch [ __ ] godzilla and king kong
punch each other in the face a lot
we got a couple of feedbacks from a
couple of santos
uh fabian santos said motu trailer yay i
did not say motu trailer
don't say that yeah joseph santos said
the fact that mark said the home run
king
makes me an even bigger fan
i do have to say with an asterisk barry
bonds is the current
home run king kind of if well that's
that's what this person said
they said they were glad that mark
called hank aaron the home run king
blackberry bonds
yeah their next sentence was no barry
bonds um
and then a guillermo dcv pointed out
that walter bernstein died at 101 years
old today
[ __ ] run yeah is that was that what
directors get 100 years
[Laughter]
i'm gonna keep making movies even if
they're yoga hosers [ __ ] who knew
all right jc what do we got
just one last thing uh maurice sucks uh
just one on dc universe infinite and
they do have
jim's superman book on that so
doesn't that story sound good it sounds
kind of dope
really good uh fat black patrick swayze
after jim's interview uh said that he
was going on and buying a whole bunch of
those books
so it worked he made the sale
excellent that's good he wasn't even
trying for the sale but good to know
that it happens
if i could fit fat black patrick swayze
on a license plate that's 100
beavis and butthead on uh comments in
the feedback says
12 hours of ryan reynolds green lantern
will not make it better i mean
fair enough depends who directed the
other 10 hours but you know
all right jc uh j
scott for real uh wants to know
what your guys awesome mix volumes would
look and sound like
uh if you guys had been abducted by the
ravagers
what's my mixtape yeah what's your guys
mixtapes
that's a great [ __ ] question
that is that that is fantastic i'm going
to read my entire spotify playlist mark
so if you want to go first
but here's the thing it would have to be
music
that not i chose but music that my
mother chose for me
oh [ __ ] then i'm gonna have nothing but
barry manilow and olivia newton-john's
song
which is okay because every time i
listen to one of those it reminds me of
my mother
yeah he's still alive so it's not like
you know it's a sad thing it's like oh
it reminds me of a happy childhood and
[ __ ] but yeah
there was a lot of like have you ever
been mellow
[Music]
nobody was like banging heads in our
house and [ __ ]
took me so much no not at all but you're
right
arcraise is an excellent point which is
make it even funner
what is the mixtape that your mom puts
together for you
or maybe it could be like older brother
and sister
no i say stick to moms we're doing
guardians honor the [ __ ] guardians
man
it's arson mix volume one for me it's
[ __ ] my mom would have wanted me to
listen to
yes um
all right um macarthur park donna summer
wow excellent pull um
the children of sanchez by chuck manzone
[Music]
um
god damn it um you'll never find by
lou rawls beautiful choice
um you're gonna miss my lovin
you're gonna miss my man
uh p-funk parliament funkadelic
make my [ __ ] the people because i want
to get [ __ ] up
um my list is not going to be nearly as
funky as yours man
no defunct on her hi-fi
not so much um
wouldn't have been there would have been
marvin gaye but not sexual healing
that's for sure
moms don't put that on your mixtape um
change is going to come sam cook maybe
your mom doesn't put it on your mixtape
from hers yes
um and i think i will i will end with
um superstition by stevie wonder
strong [ __ ] list yeah i mean i don't
know how many songs that is and there's
probably not enough but
you know we could also be here all night
trying to think of
old [ __ ] but that's that's good enough
for mine what you got
um for my the the mixtape that my mother
puts together for me
in my the guardians of the galaxy movie
of my life
um there will be barbra streisand for
sure
nice and it will probably be the
you know coming in and out of your life
that era of barbra streisand not like
funny girl and [ __ ] like that
stuff that she did with uh with barry
gibb
okay so uh i would say
um what was the one she did with barry
gibbon [ __ ]
i'm just a woman i forget but anyway
it would be just what that sounds like
yeah
um there would be olivia newton john
have you ever been mellow nothing from
greece that would be fun
but she went for the more you know uh
kind of uh heartfelt ballads and stuff
like that
um there'd be a [ __ ] ton of diana ross
that's for damn sure so the
mahogany would be there oh nice ain't no
mountain high enough
um and what's oh what's the song that
always makes me [ __ ] cry
um oh [ __ ] oh i can't even
it's giving me chills just even trying
to sing the opening line touch me in
the morning oh
oh i still remember my mother singing
that song
out loud while she was like cooking eggs
on a sunday morning and [ __ ] like that
like
diana ross reached into her soul and
made my mother sing she was not
like a singer and she would couldn't
[ __ ] stop it so
touch me in the morning mahogany ain't
no mountain high enough and then also
from her 80s stuff
you know she liked uh it's my turn as
well
um my mother liked all the i'm getting
divorced music even though she never got
divorced
like that was her therapy i guess she'd
sing them all but she stayed married
um let's see who else they're definitely
let me see
uh dolly in there i'm
for my dad for sure but not so much for
my mom like my dad was the
was the country guy which was weird
because he was from [ __ ] like
jersey um like and we lived in a
seafaring town so it's not even like you
know
well when we weren't rodeoing and [ __ ]
it's like why do you like country music
exactly
um no it wouldn't be that hold on i'm
trying to
picture the uh oh [ __ ] anne murray
love dan murray um
uh what was that one song you
you put me high upon a pedestal
so high that i can almost see eternity
you need me that was the song um
also um neil diamond
but not the one that everyone sings at
[ __ ] sporting events and street
caroline
like song some glue wasn't that one
um it was um the sad one from the jazz
singer
love on the rocks oh that one that's
that's a good mom song
and it's so weird because my mother
didn't drink you know what i'm saying
like she didn't have an unhappy marriage
as far as i know
and she didn't drink so like why did
that song appeal to her nothing about
it is in her [ __ ] venn diagram i
don't know but she loved that it's been
desired to be a boozy shantous
like love on the rocks ain't no big
surprise
drink put me a drink
um she still has christopher cross
somebody said in chat christopher cross
you're absolutely [ __ ] right what are
you [ __ ] my mom leo
how did you know about christopher cross
because she still has that's the only cd
she has in her car
i borrowed her car like two years ago
when i was driving around florida and
[ __ ]
i had to go someplace to be by myself
type of smoke and um
i was like well i'll put on some music
while i'm sitting here in the parking
lot
and so his mom got in and it's the
[ __ ] best of christopher cross man so
i was like
all right think we're gonna make it
right
and and also well i gotta be honest
though one of my favorite songs in the
world is [ __ ] christopher cross as
well i'm here i am like [ __ ] poking
fun of my mom but
the arthur song when you get caught
between the moon
and news let's see they put the name of
the movie in the [ __ ] song
like in the second [ __ ] verse he's
like arthur he does as he pleases that'd
be like [ __ ] doing a song about
clerks and you're like
dante and randall are in this that
always captured my magic
um that was a fun question man excellent
[ __ ] job jc
all right uh next question from ryan
c um
as cool and interesting as one division
is take any two
comic or pop culture characters and make
a similar show what characters would you
choose
no worries hmm any two characters well i
mean those characters were kind of
related though always
like not related like brother sister but
in comics they've always been a
team do we get to pick like we can't
it's not just like pick any two like
snoopy and [ __ ] conan the barbarian
like it should be something that makes a
little sense right like
is the question i'm kind of paraphrasing
but is the question more
who deserves a deep dive series a la
wanda vision
yeah i think so i don't think it has to
be necessarily relationship like you
could do
like jay and silent bob right two people
who are
who have that intimate kind of i did jay
and silent bob jason yeah
i've been doing it a lot my whole life
but yeah the idea of like uh in if say
in my world it would be like uh
going down the rabbit hole with like um
uh elias from clerks ii and
you know randall instead of dante
although randall's the main character
you know why am i using my own [ __ ] as
an example
um all right let me think what
characters have i always loved who
deserves
a bigger microscope on them
you got any ideas mark i got a thought
good um
two characters from the authority
um created by warren ellis apollo in the
midnighter
um apollo was you know the sun god
basically was the authorities equivalent
to superman
um jews power from the sun fairly
beautiful flies wears a bunch of spandex
midnighter was his uh version of batman
who uh who has fought every fight in the
history of the world before and so knows
how every fight is going to end so knows
exactly where to punch you to make you
hurt
um and they also happen to be lovers and
they're gay um
which again is you know of course
superman and batman would probably have
kissed once or twice just to see what
that was all about
um so so yeah like a deep dive
nodding i'm like yeah of course i guess
they would why we
we're as tight as superman and batman
we've never once been like i wonder what
it'd be like if we kissed
i imagine superman and batman though a
bit like you know bowie and jagger
where it's like listen guys we're about
as famous as famous we [ __ ] everything
anyway like
it would be just rude not to see what
this is all about
was it brando and richard pryor remember
like last year like richard brown's
ex-wife or
his wife was like pretty sure he blew
brando or some [ __ ] we were like what
yeah quincy jones was telling that story
and like i think vulture
went to like richard pryor's widow he's
like oh yeah yeah no he and brando had a
thing yeah she co-signed it she was like
yeah
yeah he did that um so yeah i think like
a deep dive into
two giant superheroes who uh the world
doesn't know is gay but totally are and
what their domestic life must be like
when you know one of them has to go and
move the sun back into orbit and another
one is just punching people to death in
the city streets but like we gotta come
home and like make dinner and [ __ ] and
maybe
you know what are we going to watch are
we going to watch snow piercer we're
going to watch [ __ ] you know reruns
of the sopranos
i think like inner domestic life of
giant superheroes who the world doesn't
quite know
are together might be interesting well
goodnight man nice pull um
ham strapped on the comments said uh he
pulled from my stuff and said pillow
pants and mr tusk and that's very sweet
but i want to point out that hamstract
earlier in the evening mark
was putting up all the lyrics for the
songs
from streets of fire
uh the one that's like man on a saturday
night
it's feeling better um so nowhere fast
i was [ __ ] delighted by that another
place another time tour in 1984 baby
that's so funny is that you're wearing
the [ __ ] shirt
what does it say ellen aim and the
attackers
another place another time tour 84.
that is [ __ ] fantastic where'd you
get that
the internet somewhere but last week we
started talking streets of fire and i'm
like i got to represent the brand yo
i've been listening to the soundtrack
all week and when i say the soundtrack i
mean i've been listening to two songs
the firing songs over and over the song
that opens the movie
and the song that closes the movie both
i believe jim steinman compositions
correctly so [ __ ] good so much so i
forced it on my kid i was like you have
to watch this clip man
and uh she was like oh my god is that
diane lane i was like yeah when she was
a kid she was like i just saw her
in a movie with laura dern and they were
in a band and i was like that's the
fabulous stains
and then diane lane was in three movies
about a girl being in a band
like they were almost back to back to
back it was kind of crazy but [ __ ]
i say i'm not saying that this one's the
best but
the one that is dearest nearest and
dearest to my heart is streets of fire
particularly for the opening and closing
sequence you can almost
you know cut the movie down to that
opening sequence and that closing
sequence and it's one of the greatest
movies ever made
the rest that happens in between it's
fine it's okay there's a lot of driving
there's some shooting
there's a lot of overhead railroads and
like
urban blight but also like pomade
but otherwise yes um
okay who would i like to see get a
um closer look so to speak
i'm gonna go deep cuts do it
it's not going to be satisfying to
anybody
appreciate the warning um
the daily planet i would like to you
know
so daley planted his background to
superman um and we get to see it
sometimes in superman's stories and
stuff but i would
i would do a show at the daily planet
like
jimmy olsen [ __ ] you know
perry white the entire staff i wouldn't
even you know i'd use lois very
sparingly and stuff because once you
use lois then [ __ ] superman comes
sniffing around and stuff
but i you know i would like to
i would do a newsroom show at the daily
planet
it's uh it's been a long time since
we've had a good newsroom
television show used to be a staple it
used to be like one of the three or four
things that they made shows about
what if we got aaron sorkin to do that
[ __ ] man aaron sorkin presents the daily
planet or aaron sorkins the planet
oh hbo max get on that
yeah but see now you just made a show
for aaron sorkin to have
good you know what dude i don't have to
have everything in fact i need nothing
i got kevin smith's [ __ ] to do look
behind me but i want to make sure that
like
seth rogen that there's [ __ ] out there
that i want to watch man so like
the idea of aaron sorkin doing like a
daily planner show and everybody talking
fast and [ __ ]
oh
i i love the world in which aaron sorkin
needs you to get him work
wow i don't know if anyone has heard of
this guy or they're sold on him but this
short can he's gonna have a future
he knows how to write a word or two all
he needs is somebody to just like
lick them up maybe shine them off a
little bit come on give this guy a shot
uh mustang 750r said didn't they try to
do a daily planet show
um i mean lois and clark was kind of
that a little bit
but i stand by my answer
all right jc go to the next one uh
touching on something you guys talked
about a couple weeks ago how about a
lando and lobot show
done they're making orlando show right
young lando
with [ __ ] with what's his name maybe
donald glover i don't know
if they do that young lobot better be in
it they better show us
him meet and lobot they better show us
lobot without the headphones
getting his thing and like lando saved
his life but he's got to wear these
things for life and that's why lobot
is like always there for him and [ __ ] or
did those things
mean that he was a was he a robot like
was he an android was he like [ __ ]
under lando's control or was he just
like his major domo
i i look forward to the to the uh to the
long period of time before you do that
like
lex luthor and smallville like didn't
lose his hair until like season four
like i was just waiting for it like no
it's timothy look at all that hair
you're never gonna cut that [ __ ] hair
off
timothy chalamet is lobot come on man
who ain't watching that [ __ ] show
they're like donald glover
is landon timothy chalamet is
global the world is like
that's awesome um all right what do you
got jc
okay last one uh from goddammit russ uh
which marvel character would you like to
see
wield a green lantern ring
wow what a great question which marvel
character
would i like to see we wear the green
lantern ring
it's got to be somebody imaginative
otherwise you get big catcher's mitts
and giant racing cars all the time
so
ooh miles morales is an artist
and he's already [ __ ] spider-man and
[ __ ] so he's already seen horrible weird
things and villains so he he's [ __ ]
he's imaginative give the ring to
someone with imagination that's the
[ __ ] key
like you know if you're if the ring
is bound to the will of the wearer to
bring
anything you can imagine to [ __ ] life
like give it to a kid kids have a mage
amazing imagination give it to
like you know an upstanding kid not some
kid that's just like the kid in the
twilight zone movie where he keeps
everybody captured in their house and
he's a little
[ __ ] mad god and [ __ ] like that but
somebody's
is creative man and in the marvel
universe
that would be miles morales in the real
world
like i would say give it to
jordan peele jj abrams
uh maybe not david lynch he's a little
too imaginative
kevin feige [ __ ] give that ring to
kevin five
[ __ ] everyone else if you're talking
marvel character kevin feige is the
ultimate marvel character stan is gone
so we can't give stan the
[ __ ] ring give it to kevin [ __ ]
feige man the only kevin that matters
and [ __ ]
if you have to give it to a fictional
character i say give it to miles what
about you
um i i kind of want to give it to a
person who doesn't have
power like i think it's more it's a
little more interesting for me if it's
not like a dude who can already do a
bunch of [ __ ]
um so like part of me almost went the
punisher just to see what exactly how
[ __ ] grim dark you can get with a
green lantern ring and frank castle just
i'm i'm making giant hammers and
everything's just everything's a nail if
you got a giant hammer
could you imagine you're the punisher
with a green lantern ring
you could kill with a thought yep
my name is a killing wound yes just
straight out dude
all the [ __ ] weaponry all the money
he would save on bullets
and guns because all he'd have to do is
just like he don't even have to leave
the house he could probably just [ __ ]
send the ring they're talking some [ __ ]
um
but then i i thought it would be really
interesting if somebody like mary jane
watson got the ring
like somebody who has been in and around
this world and has seen
you know the heroics and the the losses
and all that [ __ ]
um but who gets a chance to actually
affect change
um on a big level uh and then what that
would do for her relationship with peter
you know what happens if suddenly we're
both out there doing this crazy ass [ __ ]
what happens if i can technically do
more than you can
do what if i'm a better hero than you
peter
um i think that would be interesting
victor venn diagram and chad said you
can give the black ring to stan does
that bring people back to life
the black ring i didn't follow the
document yeah the the all the different
rings i i mean when i was
when i was reading books kid there was
one ring one ring
now they got a ring for almost every
color and stuff and i like it i like you
know it's kind of like the multiple
kryptonites and [ __ ] like that give me
one ring the silly
one ring matt garcia said give it to
aunt may what an adorable idea
no she would just wish peter out of harm
all the time
didn't you it's like i had to punch him
at me like he's the bad guy but you
could also not do that
comic san may is like oh peter uh movie
anime is like
pete leave there's a there's a young man
over because i'm st i'm still vitally
dating and
incredibly attractive
i was gonna say it'd be fun to give it
to if it was
mcu to paul rudd's ant-man
because he could get real small but make
really big things or get really big and
make really small things
true this that's true
um yeah man mary jane that's a good one
right there
that's my in chat uh j
scott for real said give it to smeagle
he loves a ring
no that's the last guy you give that
[ __ ] ring to man
um there have been quite a few give it
to howard the ducks
you're with the thanos [ __ ]
i need to rewind a minute uh lionheart
in the twitch chat
said uh what about in all in the family
but with aunt may and uncle ben
going back to the last question huh
sweet oh the one division question but
you do ant-man uncle ben
and you get a chance yes when i hear all
in the family that means that uncle ben
is like jeez you know though
daddy's people living next door like
he's you're not talking about like a
racist uncle ben are you
no
uncle ben hated black people
he doesn't say he doesn't say his famous
quote of with great power comes great
responsibility
this quote is locked the door yeah
this neighborhood
um wait where were we that was funny i
don't know
but now i'm just sort of fascinated with
racist uncle ben
in his sitcom
what a black guy on the rice they just
they just turned it on the rice
chat goes with great racism comes great
responsibility
i'm glad they don't got no mexican
superheroes oh
jeez um all right did we do
is that it did we hit do we do it three
we've answered
ye these questions three indeed
it's always a weird feeling when we run
out of show
that's it yeah i guess we'll just come
back
next week and do some more do you have
fun kids
uh if you enjoyed this show do us a
favor jump over to
keeps.com fatman
or justkeeps.com and uh go uh check out
the product
give it a give it a whirl if you can man
if you need it
if you're one of those you that don't
yeah you got here you want to keep do it
you got a lion's mane a hair
you want to keep it go to keeps
keeps.com ladies and gentlemen uh
thank you to jim krueger for coming on
tonight dropping some knowledge on us
and [ __ ] like that
talking about some good ass stories uh
thank you to jc
for as always facilitating all this
nonsense and making it happen even
remotely
uh from his home and stuff uh but there
ain't no show without the guy
sitting over there which way
yes that away ah [ __ ] you know where he
is he's down there
uh give it up for the great mark bernard
ladies and gentlemen thank you
sir thank you very much and that
uh ladies and gentlemen next week we'll
be back same time or four o'clock next
week we'll do four o'clock next week
four o'clock next week saturday we'll be
back to talk about
uh episode four of wand division maybe
episode one of uh well i'll be talking
about episode one of snow piercer of
season two probably the rest of season
one as well
um and anything else uh that happens
uh you know we'll try to keep you up to
date cause we love this [ __ ]
as much as you man i love this [ __ ] more
than i like making my own [ __ ]
there you go like fanboy first
artists second most people like second
bro
not even ninth for you whatever get off
my dick
thank you for hanging out man go visit
janesonbob.com if you want to buy some
[ __ ] with me mark where do they get your
shirt not the ellen name shirt but this
shirt that you're
always selling the other shirts at
embattledclothing.com
if you use the code mark 15 you say 15
off your first order
[ __ ] egg man there it is kids we're
selling [ __ ]
oh yeah uh there it is ladies and
gentlemen hopefully enjoy this
go enjoy the rest of your weekend man
mask up
wash your hands uh stay away from covet
and stuff like that for fat man beyond
i'm kevin smith
i'm mark bernard tune in next week
saturday at four o'clock
same fat time samefat channel
spodcast.com or
youtube.com kevin smith um normally we
quote some marvel project or some movie
we like
so i'm gonna quote one division and just
say no
you